Whoopsie, whoopsie, whoopsie.
I said, I said, man, I missed my joke.
Okay, hold on.
Redo, redo, redo, redo.
Okay.
Oh, that was it.
But I don't think it worked so well the second time.
Goodwin?
You guys hate it!
You hate it!
I know, I know, you hate it!
You guys aren't booing at all!
You hate it!
I get it.
I get it, I get it, you hate it, okay?
You're not booing at all!
I get it!
It's a good joke!
Boo?
Boo for real?
Yay!
I was saying boo.
You guys like it!
And there you go, thank you for the 10 gifted!
Hello everybody, welcome to Hell Divers.
Today I will be playing with Matara, with Haruka, and...
Ma...
And...
Uh...
And, um, and, um, my, my, my, my, and, uh, a bit of, uh, oh
gosh, with also, uh, and, um, with also, uh, HEN, HEN, HEN,
uh, I just like a normal amount, probably.
But it'll be fine.
It'll be okay.
If you're wondering where are those funny people at?
I'll tell you, I'm playing the tutorial first, and people
wanted to see a video, but it starts as soon as I, like,
open the game.
So I was like, close the game.
And so now I'm going to start the game.
Play.
That's why we're on, been on a black screen this whole time.
I hope it'll capture.
Right?
It'll capture, right?
Oh, yes.
Oh, it's, oh.
Oh,
no.
Can't, can't, can't, can't capture.
Oh, ah, ah, that's there, it's there.
Okay.
Super Earth Ministry of Truth.
Semper.
Super Earth.
Whoa.
Am I lagging?
Our home.
A tiny bit.
Prosperity.
Hi there.
Oh my god, neighborhood.
Friendly.
Oh.
Democracy.
Our way of life.
Oh, we're a happy family.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
No, sweet liberty.
No, no, the liberty.
Invasion.
Oh my god, he's in grief.
He's in so much grief, he's hallucinating his family.
You could be next.
Me?
That is, unless you make the most important decision of your
life.
What's that?
Shaves my head?
The strength and the courage to be free.
I'm free, I'm free.
Join the hell divers.
Peacekeeping force.
These suits are so sexy.
Yeah!
Oh my god, I love him!
Ah!
And spread managed democracy.
Oh, yeah!
Become a hero.
Become a legend.
Wow, that should be me in that plane.
Become a Helldiver.
A Helldiver.
That's us today.
That's us four.
Sorry that I'm lagging a little bit.
I'm going to fix some settings once it lets me.
Top secret.
Age.
Oh my gosh.
That's, wait.
Oh, average age, maybe.
The game is too high quality.
I can't believe we're actually going to become hell divers.
Oh my god.
Me neither, girlfriend.
Next recruit prepared to smelt.
Archie, hell's sake.
Liberating the galaxy?
Stomping bugs?
They're bugs.
Every kid's dream.
What kind of psychopath kid are you?
Good luck out there.
Thank you.
I'll see you on the front lines.
Okay.
Earn your cake.
Whoa.
You're on your own to find your way to the training
facility.
Bye, P-Quad.
okay hold on let's see oh this is me okay hold on let's see
display um let's see not ultra quality maybe just regular
quality um let's see frame rate limit let's just uh why
won't it let me oh frame rate limit on let's do like 60 i
don't think i don't think any more will do anything on on uh
youtube anyway um uh the v sync on um well no wait v i can
never remember is it oh wait oh gosh i'm lagging still 269
stop you guys stop
if you are lagging.
Okay, let's apply this.
Oh!
Would you look at that?
Already fixed.
Is there a motion blur or anything like that?
Oh, motion blur?
Ooh.
Maybe we can turn it like a little bit on.
Like 50%.
Yeah.
Zero?
Zero motion blur?
You sure?
Is it sure?
Okay, I'll turn it off.
I'll turn it off.
Okay.
Let's see how this works now.
Quickly as possible.
Thank you.
Have a good day.
Good.
Thank you.
Oh, where do I go?
Tab to view the map.
I need to go that way.
Hold right click while map is open.
Oh, oh neat.
I gotta get my cake.
Welcome to Helldiver training.
Your instructor is waiting for you, Abad.
Please proceed.
Uh, how do I do anything?
See you on the other side.
You do.
I'm General Fresh.
most grizzled war hero and i'm not easy to impress hell
diver training is the toughest test in the galaxy but i can
tell that doesn't scare you impressive now enough jib-jab
the upcoming obstacles will take everything your exceptional
physique can muster this is it the real deal get to it
soldier
Okay, let's see the crouch.
Or sprint.
Okay, nice.
Okay, I'm earning this cape with flying colors.
Traverse obstacles.
Ugh!
Easy!
In all my years, I've never witnessed such acrobatic
perfection.
Dive?
I think you're ready for our highly realistic battlefield
simulator.
That's right.
the real deal okay dive alt wait alt oh oh what did i just
press oh dive hello oh i was pressing x on accident okay do
i have to oh this is fine everybody um i i dove um okay
Wait, hold on.
Dive here.
Huh.
The aliens have guys?
I always say the best simulation is a real simulation.
Now, activate the battlefield injury simulator.
Battlefield injury simulator.
Beep-oop.
Oh, that's not a simulator.
I think I'm actually dying.
Chief soldier, grab that stim and pat yourself off.
Oh, nice.
Oh, use the sting.
Freedom never sleeps.
That's me.
I said that.
Freedom never sleeps.
You're about to encounter democracy sworn enemy recruit.
All right.
I wonder...
What am I... Oh, um...
There it is.
The terminate.
The scourge of liberty.
Arm yourself and show that bug, the true meaning.
of freedom.
It's in our position.
Now, use the grenade to close up that bug hole.
Otherwise, they'll just keep coming.
Grenade!
Uh, G to quick throw a grenade.
Uh, how do I throw?
Oh!
What a catapult of an arm!
On to the next section.
Okay.
Um, no diving.
No diving.
Look up in the sky, recruit.
Up there is a super destroyer and it's all powerful
stratagems.
I was like that Control Use a stratagem now to take care of
those bugs.
I think they need combat Make sure you take a few steps back
Um To dial oh, beep boop.
Oh, I see it up there.
I see it up there and uh, fire Wait, I think did I throw it
too far?
Uh
Okay, hold on.
Oh, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't
come here.
Oh.
Easy.
Oh,
I don't have enough.
Beep, beep, boop.
One more.
To here.
Look at their hungry.
Who am I to...
Who am I to blow these guys up?
They're just trying to live, right?
The will of democracy.
Oh, for democracy.
that's why next lesson oh hell divers fight in squads meet
your new squad I love cardboard man what a fine soldier your
brother and arms a battle forged bond that could never be
replaced until now here's your real lesson soldier squad
mates can and will perish tragically all the time now use
the reinforcement strategy to have another hell diver take
their place what Putting in the Konami code up in here.
Oh, a ball!
Here!
Ooh!
What?
Oh my god!
Like he never left.
How do I know which one I'm selecting though?
This is the real deal.
It's just you, the gun in your hands, and 2,000 megatons of
explosives in close orbit.
that's it wait okay so how do i know which one i'm selecting
okay wait hard reload what's three piece of advice moving
around makes it hard to aim for a list accuracy stay still
while you shoot oh stay still do you want me to die oh my
god oh my god I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die!
Oh!
Wait, how do I switch to the grenade?
Oh, that's not a grenade.
Oh, bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl-bl- Three?
Where's the
grenade?
Oh, gee!
Uh-oh.
Uh, reload.
Oh, shh.
Oh, god.
I'm gonna...
Oh, no, don't go confused.
Ah!
Aji!
Oh, jee!
Oh, some thinking bugs!
No!
Oh!
a chance against a genius tactical mind like a genius you
are literally invincible yeah
can i keep going let's go watch out for falling hell pot
it's finally time to call in the big guns use the support
weapon stratagem to get yourself a real weapon
You are literally title car.
Literally invincible.
Oh, uh, throw down.
Hello?
Where's my gun?
I did it wrong!
Oh, okay.
Well, it looked like it was kind of busy up in here, you
know?
So, okay, there.
Good time.
me wow oh my god that's the stuff now use a resupply
strategy to get yourself some more ammo okay uh how do i
know what i'm oh i see i see so you put in the code for
whichever one that you want so if i want to summon a person
i put in that up up down down hello um i'm gonna die here if
you don't hurry The DDR goes?
Load up, soldier.
Because playtime's over, you've reached your final test.
Oh, no.
This is the real deal.
Get to it.
Okay.
I'm scared.
This area is in dire need of liberation from the Terminate
Scourge.
Activate that terminal.
I'm activating.
I'm activated.
Oh.
DDR!
I'm going liberation I've never seen such flawless terminal
activation now somewhere around here is the flag of super
earth find it and plant it where all can see its democratic
glory this that's the flag of super earth yep planted in the
designated area here we own this place now no I'm sure you
show us a proper respect.
Salute!
Yeah!
Ah!
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
Oh, oh, oh!
Why are you still alive?
More prosperity!
Oh, we did it.
Already you've advanced the cause of debauchery I've ever
seen.
Oh my god.
You've proved your worth.
You're ready to don your cape.
That's me, that's me.
Oh, contract.
Wait, I thought this was a wall of like superhero, best
people.
Wait, wait, there's a contract?
Wait, wait, wait.
Termination!
Hold on.
This agreement will be governed by the laws of super earth
and shall be terminated in the event that the enlisted is
mortally wounded such that medical attention shall not be
physically or financially- What do you mean?
My health is not financially justifiable.
don't read this don't don't read it they care about me they
gave me a cape you guys there's more wait wait there's
there's actually more oh wait wait wait okay it's kind of
the same okay i'm gonna do like a slow walk okay this is the
slowest i can go i think get me my cape We did the contract
as a pilot.
Ooh!
I wish I could jump.
And vulnerable and seven feet tall.
You're finally ready for the realest deal of them all.
The galactic war.
Oh, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Democracy, justice.
They're in your hands now.
General crush, over and out.
Over and out.
She crouching.
Is it a requirement to be seven feet tall or...
How long do you think all these guys had to wait in these
pods for?
They were like, God, I hope this guy finishes soon.
Woohoo!
Mint right down level one cadet!
They're frozen to worry.
Just like my dinner.
Yippee!
Mars!
Of destruction!
It's the best anime ever.
Oh!
Name your super destroyer ship.
Let's see.
Oh no.
You guys, what should we name it?
What should we name it?
Dream of battle.
Let's see what else we got on here.
Democracy, it's a big one.
It's a cool one.
I bet they're waiting on me, so I don't want to take so
long.
Independence.
Iron.
Law, liberty.
Patriotism.
Pride.
Science.
Oh my gosh, this is too much pressure.
This is too much pressure.
Judge of judgment.
Fist of war.
Maybe I just...
Founding father of war.
Wait, was there patriots?
Patriots?
Panther.
Ombudsman?
Patriot?
Where is there?
Sons?
Patriot?
Someone said family, right?
Patriot of family values Patriot of patriotism That's even
better I'm the patriot of patriotism The most patriotic you
could ever get Patriot Patriot Of patriotism
It's written right there Oh my gosh that was awesome Oh okay
oh there's even more wow congratulations on completing
training hell diver thank you you're in charge of this
vessel now the democracy officer awaits you on the bridge
welcome to the galactic war thanks all right wow oh my gosh
these uniforms are so sexy though right look how cool we
look wow nice okay guys i'm glad that we could warm up with
you or i could warm up with you guys because i i'm so
nervous oh i am so nervous to collab with henya but we're
gonna have fun okay the lalilol of lalilolism
you get to meet eroshi today i It's, um, you know, because I
collabed with Haruka before, a couple years ago, actually.
Um, I mean, well, I haven't streamed for a couple years, but
we, um, we played Among Us together.
I believe it was Among Us.
And, of course, Matara.
Henya.
Mom's spaghetti.
That's me.
Oh, God, my tummy hurts.
Okay, let me let them know that I'm ready.
I'm, I'm ready now.
we're all waiting hello hi you're huge i thought you were
above i gotta shoot you wait hello hello i can hear you back
on your i think all my hold on all my settings are messed up
because i moved my computer yesterday give me one second um
you're messed up hello
her hello
hi it's
a nice weather isn't it today yeah it's good weather
yeah it's good weather hello sorry uh i disconnected it was
really weird
Is everything okay with you?
Wait, why are you throwing up after you're talking to me?
You didn't even join the conference!
I enjoyed it too much!
I like- Why are you throwing up?
Why are you throwing up, Dayo?
Hello!
Hi, Haru.
Oh, did I join it?
Hi!
Hi, Minto!
They're already arguing.
It's been forever!
Yay!
Yeah!
It's been forever!
The only time we collab is when!
you graduated now you're back i was just saying that i was
like it's been a long time it's just like three years i know
three years we were mutuals and everything we were too shy
to talk to each other and now we're here now we're here yay
sorry mr tuba like i said i'll boot up the game i'm so happy
to collab with you guys Yeah, I was so excited!
Yeah!
I'm eating an egg sandwich, so I hope you don't mind my
food.
I had an egg sandwich!
Oh my god, they're the same person.
Is it from Tim Hortons?
No, I got them from a store.
They have an egg sandwich.
A store.
Yeah, they have an everything sandwich.
Hold on, let me turn to you guys.
You're all not very loud.
I think you're very loud for me.
I'm always very loud.
I had a collab, and every streamer was yelling in it, and
now I have all the quiet girls.
was ironic considering i shot all the time but you always
seem to catch me when i just woke up every time i collab
with hadu she just wakes up ohio ohio ohio all right i'm
gonna open the game min do i have you at it because you can
jump off of me to get into the game oh yes i i have you how
do i jump off of you so you're gonna open my name and then
you're just gonna do a join game from there.
It's pretty easy.
You can figure it out, my love.
Hi, hi.
I believe in you.
I'm done.
Yeah.
I'm so excited.
Thank you for joining me.
Basically, we got...
Hanya and I are fairly new to the game.
Mint, this is gonna be your first time.
My first time.
But Haruka is a pro.
Yeah, she is like...
She'll be doing all the stuff.
She'll be explaining how to do stuff while the three of us
will probably just run around yelling.
Yeah, Haruka carry da yo Haruka carry da yo Haruka carry da
yo
It's true It's true I'm looking I'm have I see you Yeah wait
play wait I click wait Hold on I have to get in the game
first Okay And then you can get in Have some patience, Mint.
I don't even see where I say to join.
You'll see it once I'm in the game and, like, yeah.
Try it now.
Oh, join it.
You're so smart.
Oh, it's so beautiful.
It's so humble.
Yippee.
Allied Destroyer.
Is there an in-game chat or?
Oh, there is.
Yeah, you can type.
But we're going to be in Discord and talk.
talking to one another.
How, what would you say is your experience, mid-Faltoe, with
shooting games?
I'm really good.
Uh-huh.
Nice.
Oh, mid-toe.
Yeah.
You want to, hold on.
I have food in my mouth.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
If you want to turn off your microphone.
Oh.
Press escape.
Uh-huh.
Go to options.
Go to audio.
Uh-huh.
And there's voice chat.
Because I think you have...
broadcast microphone so i could hear myself and you oh i'm
sorry no no yeah she had it is that better it's okay guys oh
yeah yeah okay she's new to streaming she hasn't i'm new to
streaming yeah she's new to streaming she's got to learn i
should say i'm rusty she hasn't streamed in three years yeah
be nice to me exactly exactly exactly fuck you i love you
Oh boy.
Now this is how you know we're friends.
Yeah.
Yay!
Friend, I am.
We've been, technically we've been friends for almost four
years.
If you really think about it.
Yeah, that's interesting.
That is kind of crazy.
Yeah.
Will you defend it?
Wow.
I still remember when you first debuted, you were this cute
little ghosty ghost.
Stop.
You're talking about me like that, mom, you're embarrassing
me.
And now she's old.
And now you're old.
I still remember when you debuted this model too, and I was
so emotional.
I was like, oh my god, there's my baby little bit.
Aww.
Let's try it on three instead of seven for difficulty.
Okay, three.
Yeah, and then we'll ramp it up if Mint is comfy.
But basically Mint, you have to fight either the bugs, my
cousins, or you gotta fight the robots.
Okay.
I say at the start, the bugs are much easier because the
robot shoot back at you oh yeah that's bad uh if you have
any questions please like ask ahead right this is one of
those uh do you get the weapons are they are the weapons osp
what's an osp are they do you get them do you bring them
with you or do you get them like there uh you bring them
with you but you have to summon them it's called strategy
jims ask us anything honestly ask us anything We'll yawn at
you.
We'll teach you.
I'm gonna run around.
I'm gonna look at my cape.
It's really flowy.
I recommend sticking with a buddy.
I recommend you stick with Hanya.
And I'll be with you guys often.
Oh, hey, man.
Is this Hanya?
I'm a Hanya?
Yeah, no, that's not Hanya.
Wait.
That's our commander.
Oh, God.
Yeah, that's me, Hanya, Daniel.
She's talking with the wrong person.
I love it.
She's a big muscular man.
are so big.
Your brain is so large.
I have been working all day.
Oh, thank you.
Where do I go?
Do I go into a little hell pod?
At the end of the ship, there's like a little pod and you go
into it.
Oh, here.
My very own hell pod.
Yeah.
So basically, like, you choose a mission the person who
started.
What about here?
And then you here pick, like, your stuff.
As you gain more levels, you'll be able to have more
stratagems and, you know, you have more of them, pick more
of them.
Okay.
So I just have very few oh what's this oh yeah just just add
anything and then play around with it see how you like it
okay oh this one oh i can't you guys look so cool thanks i
got it from ebay oh wow i bought 100 on ebay what there's
even ebay on super earth my mom confiscated my credit card
oh i can't buy anywhere i already know it's because you
bought those robux i did the robux i don't know what it is
but i did buy it the fortnight money not the fortnight oh
wait extra party can i equip it i won't let me equip i
usually you can i think if you press r you'll be able to
equip in the equipments yeah this one oh wait how do i get
oh ready yep sorry i'm ready i think i don't worry you'll
see like As you get into the game, it's a lot at first to
kind of...
But now the best part is coming, Min.
Are you ready?
Oh, yeah.
You know what's really funny?
I have the comfiest music playing right now.
You have what?
You're doing what?
I have the comfiest music playing in my ears right now.
Are you listening Shalala?
Shalala!
I should be singing Chihuahua.
Yay!
If anybody saw the Vishojo concert, it's the Henya and
Haruka.
Duo song.
Yeah, I linked the song.
Oh, and there's friendly fire, by the way.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
You have to...
Nice.
I'm alive.
There's a little jellyfish.
You know how to summon your items?
Control, right?
Yeah.
which what is it ddr is it resupply uh no it's your weapon
you have like a little gun that you can order uh yeah yeah
yeah i just clicked the resupply um yep oh wait nice
resupply yep nice resupply oh i see it the machine gun right
yeah and then tab is your uh tab is your map yeah you open
up your map i'm gonna grab yeah well there you go so
basically um if you run ammo we always like to get a
resupply over here okay also we're a sheep um emma's punch
ah f you bitch you bitch v is your um is your uh what is it
called a stim oh oh okay yeah i can give i can give and then
you have your gun number one gun Gun number two, also scroll
wheel.
Oh, you can also scroll wheel it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right?
You can scroll wheel the gun.
Oh, wait, no.
I don't think so.
The gun.
Yeah, my bad.
It's only wrong game.
Wrong game.
Can I pick these up?
Which ones?
Oh, see, there's little bugs coming up.
So, these little guys right here.
I have no idea how to play these.
Ask their bugs.
That's their guys.
Ah!
You gotta shoot them.
It's been a while.
You see that orange thing on the ground?
That means it's a bug breach.
So they're coming up to attack us.
Okay.
That red thing is I'm summoning.
Be careful.
Stay away from that.
Oh.
I'm fine.
Yeah.
So you'll see.
You'll get there.
It's a lot of food.
Are we going to the orange thing?
Orange is the main mission.
Usually Haru and I like to like run around and do random
stuff.
How do you go to the orange?
Oh, tab.
Okay, I see it.
I know it's a little stressful at first.
Feel free to ask anything.
That's why.
Yeah.
Okay.
Whatever.
the jellyfish they're so cute yeah there's different planets
which do different stuff super credit nice yeah i got us
some i got you babe thank you got you super credit the red
if you look on the map there's like big red kind of yeah
yeah that's usually an enemy nest yeah oh i blew up a
something and exploded on me good i think oh don't worry
that's uh normal i mean to like you things nipply nipply
things they look like onion so if you run into them they
create like this fog and i think they help with avoiding the
bugs because bugs rely oh they actually help you oh no no no
no uh i'm getting that except the robots rely on sight bugs
do not oh yeah but also i think it's like it slows the bugs
down a little bit doesn't it i do not know i think i thought
it slowed them down a little tiny bit i forget the big the
big orange thing where do you aim at the face or you aim at
his ass no not the charger the the thick orange one that his
face oh his face yeah you aim oh is that guy over there do
you see this shoot him shoot him shoot him get him kill him
over there shoot him you see this thing do not shoot him
it's a hell bomb oh okay shoot it All right, so if I back it
up, now let the demons win this one now watch what happens
That's really good for hordes.
Oh
We we we love explosions.
We love explosions my samples Samples is like what you take
to upgrade your ship slowly.
You're always gonna need common sense Where do you get the
items?
Where are you finding these?
It's on the ground.
Oh, do not go in there, Henya.
Don't worry, you'll get better at spotting them, my love.
Okay.
Like, trust me, even me, sometimes I have a hard time, like,
running around and figuring out where I'm going.
I got you.
I got it.
Nice!
I dropped a grenade!
Did you guys see that sick throw that I didn't fuck up
twice?
How are you all the way over there?
Who?
I saw it.
I saw you through the two grenades over there.
Oh my god.
You know what, Henya?
No, no resupply.
I'm gonna die here actually.
Oh, oh, oh.
I misplayed so bad.
She's dead.
So this is what you could do.
So you can reinforcements.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Try, try it.
What do I do?
How do I do?
Control and then you go up down, right, left, up.
Oh, up down.
What a gamer.
I know.
That was gaming.
Yeah.
And now she'll summon.
There you go.
Come on.
Come in.
Watch out.
You might die to the helipod.
I'm coming.
Okay.
Meow.
Oh, there you are.
This is meowing.
Blood breach detected.
So, Mitt, you know how you like are low on supplies?
Since I have a supply pack, I can give you a refill.
Oh, okay.
Thanks.
Wait, how do you know I'm low on supplies?
Because the little diamond on your chest is glowing.
It does.
Watch out.
Oh, there's a red one.
I forgot I have the impact grenade.
It's kind of harder to hit.
Oh, I think I'm dead.
Okay.
One second.
She's dead.
I was killed by myself.
Take my eagle.
Oh, wait.
Where did he go?
I had the impact grenade.
Oh, I shouldn't use the machine gun.
You're right.
One more.
Oh wait, no.
Get her hand, yeah.
Oh shit, whoa, I'm right there!
I'm right here!
Good job.
Nice!
Alright, so over here, Min.
You'll be a natural in no time, Min.
Don't even sweat it.
This is one of the missions.
So if you open up your map, you see how it's orange?
Yeah.
That's one of the main missions.
Oh.
So this one is upload data.
So basically do the stratagem thing.
But you just see how it's glowing.
Oh yeah, yeah, I see it.
Yeah.
And then you just basically just stand here and protect the
area.
Oh, okay.
I can do that.
Until it uploads all the corn into that thing.
Yeah, corn.
What?
This is corn.
No, no, no, no, no.
Corn.
This is the corn, the glowing pieces.
I think corn.
Corn!
Oh, Hanya, what's the word you learned the other day?
Mint, you're gonna...
Canto!
She's serving.
Wait, what?
I'm serving canto!
I tried to tell her not to, but...
Oh, you're serving Kant?
I'm so proud of you, Henya!
Yay!
Thank you!
This is my day four, serving Kanto!
My new job?
Kanto!
No, no, no, no, no.
If you really want to emphasize that, you're gonna say Kant
without the too.
Kanto!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Yeah!
That's what I'm tired of it.
It's really hard on my wife!
You!
My...
Both of my Oshis are always serving.
Wait, who's your other Oshis?
Kiwawa.
Oh, Kiwawa!
Oh, it's true!
She does!
Yeah!
My Zen Biden!
Oh, there's throwing up on us!
Shoot him at the face, mid!
Oh, I'm trying to run away!
Wait, how do I get to my machine gun, you guys?
You have to...
You can see on your map if you maybe dropped it.
Oh, I dropped it?
afraid to use um to use uh alt to jump out of attacks if you
notice that like the monsters are coming in or they're
shooting you or anything oh also reload is like you you
should not do the reload until your ammo runs out too yeah
okay so you know in some games like here if you have a
little bit of ammo and you use it it loses the full ammo oh
really i know it feels overwhelming at first baby but don't
worry i'm okay you'll get the hang of it real quick i'm just
shooting I'm running and shooting.
Good, good, good.
Running and gunning.
That's my girl.
Running and shooting.
Actually, I can summon your shield.
It's going to help you.
Over here.
So if you'll wind up your tank, you see this white icon.
Yeah, let's do a...
Haru, do you want to do the blue mission or show them?
Oh, yeah.
Let's get the weapon thing.
Blue.
Well, once you're done with the mission, the longer the
mission goes, the harder it gets because there's more bugs
that spawn.
And at the end, all the bugs on the map come to you.
What?
if you have extra time you should always try to do side
missions so the blue on the map if you open tab you see a
little blue thing that's a side mission okay so we're gonna
give us a little bit more oh this you should come get your
stuff over here mint format yep okay wait where are you i
see yeah exclamation mark mint i see people in chat are
wondering who mint is exclamation mark mint hi it's me she's
uh she's my pod gal it's a me oh shit oh she's out here
flaming yeah wait okay i already have one i think wait how
do i change all right i'm good okay there we go we're good
i'm good we're gonna make min do the mission okay okay i
want to watch her suffer me yeah it's not actually suffering
the mission You're so cruel.
Mind that just has skill issues.
I got you.
I'm joking.
I got you, baby girl.
I don't think you heard me about that.
What am I here?
I'm ready for this?
I'm ready.
This way, this way, this way.
Okay.
Go to this terminal.
I'm here.
I'm ready.
I'm at the terminal.
Oh, yeah.
Put in the Kadabi code once it shows up.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, terminal.
Yep, yep, yep.
Do it.
Put it in.
Wait, what it is.
What is?
Pressing again.
What it is.
Oh!
There you go.
And I hate always getting behind this little guy.
There we go.
Oh my god, this is me.
I'm spreading lies on the internet.
Stop spreading.
I'm uploading lies.
This one's a churning the tower, so do you see this thing
rising up?
Yes, I see it.
So usually, this is a two-person mission.
do one person because all you have to do is spin this thing
and if you hear the beep on the terminal then that means you
have successfully aligned it so henya will turn it and you
can go back to the terminal and you can tell her which
direction to turn it oh yeah i'll turn it i'll turn it wait
how do i which way what i'll do you can go to the terminal
mint and then you can tell henya where to turn oh yeah yeah
i'm gonna spin this okay i got this i got this um uh uh you
uh If the line is in between the dotted lines in this little
colored area, that's one.
That away.
Wait, what?
Don't...
Oh, he wait.
I don't know.
You're right there.
That's good.
There's a guy coming.
I think I'm gonna die here.
I am yelling.
Is he here?
Um, how do...
Would you forgive me if I summon a resupply?
I would.
Bitch!
I'm okay!
I killed him.
Wait, how far should I keep going?
I don't I don't know I don't know what I don't know what I
just did but I did something you did great that's all you
need to know You did amazing Really did I know that was a
radar tower so if you open up your map and zoom out you can
see see all those diamond shit yeah and all the things that
we can clear oh yeah we can get all of that oh yeah now we
know where to go diamond shit oh I love the treasures oh
watch out oh I'm not trying to all right I might need a wait
why can't I oh reload you might be out of ammo hey which is
why I'm here to give you recess line thanks and now I'm out
of my backpack uh-oh Uh...
Yes, ma'am?
Nothing!
I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Don't worry.
I'm good.
Yay!
Oh, I see you're exploding things!
Diving time!
Diving!
I am living my best life.
I'm just like a diamond.
It looks like you're in trouble, my friend.
I'm here to help.
Ow!
Ooh, ow!
I am shining like a diamond.
I can't see- Oh!
Thank you!
Oh, oh, what's this?
Where's the resupply?
Oh, how do I take this?
Oh, there's a supply over here.
I don't think you can really see it because...
Where's the resupply?
Did I not summon it?
There's diamond over here.
Wait.
You guys...
Did I forget to summon the resupply?
Did I screw it up?
Oh, that's a thing.
I got the airstrike.
Is it on shoulder?
Wow!
You can't move in the fire, Daya!
Here, I can summon it.
Yeah!
Okay, yeah, perfect.
Oh, uh, oh, I had forgotten to summon the resupply.
My bad.
I got your back.
Oh, I think I'm dead!
I got you, I got you!
You're alive, you're alive!
Thank you.
Oh, no!
Wait, no!
I already called,
I already called, no worries.
I got a stim.
I got another resupply.
Hold on.
Feed mommy.
Wait, wait.
Okay, give me.
Thanks, baby.
Did it work?
No problem.
Thank you, Daya!
Okay!
You're doing great, Mint.
I didn't do that, though.
You're doing really good, Mint.
I didn't do anything.
I didn't even do...
I mean, at first you just gotta get used to like the
positioning and stuff like that, right?
I'm gonna go get the stuff that you dropped back here.
Oh!
All the white icons?
Yeah!
Oh, I'll come with...
Oh yeah, Mint, Mint, Mint!
Yeah.
Next game, I'm gonna summon a shield for you.
It's gonna help you a bit with like getting hurt.
Okay!
It'll absorb a few damage and then it respawns.
It's because she's far now.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What the hell is a fire?
Kill the fire.
One thing is, well, so sometimes when we get into big bug
fights, like when the bug breach happened or anything, we,
usually what we do is like we alternate using our big
abilities.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I'm listening.
Which is like when you call in from the ship, that really
helps.
I died.
Who wants to reinforce her?
I'm busy.
I got it.
There you go.
I did it.
Are my egos forever?
Because I feel like I've had so many of them.
Egos are unlimited compared to lizard.
Oh, I didn't realize.
Oh, wow.
There's a lot of guys.
Oh, yeah.
That's why I always...
I love it.
I'm so good for the, yeah, for clearing the nest.
Get some.
Looking for the samples while I'm here.
Yeah.
I hate spears.
reinforcement oh shoot oh shoot i think i'm in trouble i
think i'm in trouble you're fine you're fine take my ego
take my ego oh my god i i'm dead i'm so dead wait did i kill
you sorry oh i can't go rearm I got you out of here.
Well, I summon you, Hado, okay?
That's really hot.
I don't want to summon you.
No?
It's called Mistake, you know?
Mistakes were made.
Is there a good way to see where I dropped my stuff?
Oh, maybe over here.
If you look at your map, it's going to show you where your
stuff was.
What does it look like?
Maybe that?
It looks like a gun.
It looks like the icons of your stratagems.
For example.
It looks like a gun that I love that.
No, I think I helped.
The yellow symbol.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, I'm going the wrong way.
Yeah, you'll, trust me, even I, like, completely lose myself
in this game, and I play it quite a bit.
Play a sample.
Oh, someone's machine gun.
Oh my god, the stupid impact grenades!
Is it mine?
Oh my god, I missed every single shot that I took.
I cannot believe this.
It was mine.
This is my gun.
Mata, do you require assistance?
I have one big battery left!
And I missed it.
Sweet liberty!
Liberty, liberty!
Come here for a second, actually.
This actually works out.
This here is called a friendship door.
I'm coming.
I have a minute and a half left before my other stuff pops
up.
It's fine.
I'll just wait.
What's this thing?
Yeah?
Go to that yellow thing, and you and Henya hit it at the
same time.
Oh, no.
You don't have to count down, but like, Henya can hit it?
I love you so much.
Oh no, come here!
Over here!
Thanks for hanging out.
This way!
We're teaching men how to play this game.
Here?
Down there!
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah!
Ready?
Boop!
Hold on, I can't use them.
Now you can get the shit in there.
Oh!
There's a shit!
Yeah, go ahead, you said!
It's a shit!
What's in there?
Shit!
Oh, there's grenades in here!
Oh, we got breakfast system slips, which is really nice too.
I have to use my grenades.
You can shoot the cylinders that sparks.
Oh.
Thank you.
I had no idea.
There's.
Oh, no.
Oh, there's little buddies that are dead here.
33 seconds.
He's just sleeping.
He's fine.
I crashed.
Oh, no.
Oh,
the other cylinders.
Thank you.
Hey.
All right.
20 seconds.
Oh, wait.
Hey, Mint.
Yeah.
Can you come here for a second?
my arc thrower in there weird request uh-huh can you punch
me oh do you think that's gonna work i'm stuck yeah oh i oh
there you go thank you thanks yeah i don't i don't think i
work i don't think i have a i don't have a good punch only
bloody it a little bit well i might have broken two my
ankles this might be a dumb question but will i die in the
fire yes yes i'm missing a grenade so i can't i've got okay
there we go never mind yeah thank you oh I'm sorry I had
already summoned the eagle when she came in.
Wow, wow, wow.
Wow, wow.
Oh, yeah.
Since, uh, since Mint is here, I'm gonna summon you a
shield.
Okay.
Where are you?
I'm here.
I'm here in front of you.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, you'll see the little shield.
This?
Yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let it drop.
Don't stand under it.
I should have let you stand under it.
I was like, wow, that's a cool looking shield.
Wow.
You'll see like right now I have to like I'm going to you
but it's it's touching the shield instead of you.
Oh, so you can handle it.
Oh, by the way, this is a bug breach.
Do you see it right there?
That's a bug breach, baby.
What's a bug breach?
So usually the bugs, it's like little patrols that they
send.
So when you see that, that means we're getting attacked by
like a group of bugs, which is fine.
It happens quite often.
It happens.
You know, it's just life.
It's my cousin would be sad for the family.
I'm gonna go get a shiny for him.
Oh!
Mata, you have to protect Minda and Arpa ha- Oh, actually,
is it...
Oh my God, I'm gonna die!
I'm gonna die!
Just run, just run.
If you're like outnumbered, just run.
I'm trying to run!
Just keep running, keep running.
You got something?
You have a friendship door that I need to assist with.
Run and then turn back and get out of it.
That's usually the way.
You run and gun into us and then we run and gun and help.
I have Haru Nya.
door to open.
Oh, shoot.
It is what it is.
And now I'm here for Harunya!
Harunya!
Ready!
I think Harunya is cute, but I think Hentara is better.
Hentara?
That's my favorite ship, Hentara.
I think that's, I think you're biased.
I said, Masha, I thought you were trying to get my visa.
Yeah, you're trying to get our visa.
Yeah, my visa, my precious visa, dao.
You got good shit in there, Hentara.
I mean...
you know one doesn't help the other I can think you're very
cute come here shoot this explosive barrel right here hang
along with me shoot yeah let's go let's go where this red
one hang along hang along this one we'll make our way down
oh sorry okay okay where are we going I would run away if I
were here on the map oh oh we got some stuff though what's
that arc throw oh the blue one oh you gotta gotta I'm coming
Stop!
Don't touch my stuff!
Wait!
Oh wow!
This is some cool stuff!
Wow!
Nice!
Yeah, I'm gonna just...
Stop touching my stuff!
I think it's just ammo.
Time to go.
Ow!
Uh...
Also, get into the habit if somebody dies in front of you
just to resummon them right away.
How do I...
Extraction is available.
It would be a good habit.
Wait, how do I use your gun?
I took your gun and I know how to use it!
Okay, okay.
No fun.
It doesn't have bullets.
can shoot it and then you have to let it cool down like it
gets red because it's it's an energy gun oh but it's good
can i get summoned back please um oh i think i think i'm
gonna die i think i'm um i believe in you i think i'm in
trouble a little bit i believe in you you got you got it i
have no i have no god um wait maybe this one oh this one
also i'm sorry i just found the penis polite society we're
the polite society that doesn't look like it that doesn't
look like it call her bad in front of mint please she's
gonna get embarrassed that person needs to go to hospital
how's that any different what's happening but look that
means slay mouse told me about it that means slay yeah don't
say it to your father she was asking if you could say that
to her dad What about if I already did?
Oh, and what did he say?
Oh, he was laughing about it, and who told you that?
And I said, now, so he was like, oh, is that the one girl
who played Fortnite?
And she's fine.
She's cool.
Because he loves Fortnite.
Oh, he's not like other dads.
He's a cool dad.
I'm sorry.
I dropped your stuff.
It's fine.
You guys want to go to the attraction zone?
There's more Shania's to go.
He's a gigachad?
Oh, I'm going to go.
All right, I'm going to start.
okay um mint and henya come with me we're gonna so do you
see once you're done with the main mission do you see the
blue light on your map you can also find it on your map but
that's where we gotta go we gotta defend that zone for about
two minutes i don't see a blue light do you see like right
in front of you do you see there's a blue light going up to
the sky oh that one yeah yeah yeah yeah we're gonna run to
it because there's no once you've like collected mostly
everything there's not really a use i'm getting the other
one what do you think i'm getting the other two also meant
well when i first played this game all i did was run after
people so don't worry if it takes you a little moment to
like get used to the game i've been shooting that's what i
still do yeah i still i'm i still run after people yeah yeah
i was full of people because i don't know where to go yeah
this is why i invited haruka because i'm okay with doing
missions but i needed some who's like good with doing
missions hi i'm decent yeah you're great god gamer now
you're a god gamer when we play on high difficulty haruka's
soloing she's doing crazy stuff oh get him in
mowing him down mowing him down okay kill the one that with
the orange he's summoning more yeah oh this guy wait but
it's okay excuse me when you see him like poop Or in front
of the air.
Yeah.
It's because he's summoning guys.
Don't worry.
I'm dying to be busy.
I just think it just went down the wrong tube.
You okay?
I'll activate.
It happens.
So I don't want to scare you girls, but we're about to get a
lot of bugs.
They're all about to come to us, which is why you always
should try to finish the missions not super late on high
difficulties.
Oh my god.
Don't spit on me.
I think we'll be fine at level two.
Oh yeah, we'll be more than fine, but...
Oh, shit.
I think we should turn it up a bit.
I'm down for four.
I think that'd be pretty fine.
Let's try four and then we'll see how.
Rilo!
Ouch!
I wish I had my machine!
Eagle!
You can summon another one.
Oh my god.
You're right.
Oh.
Yeah, they go on cooldowns.
They go on cooldowns.
Summon the one you want.
getting attacked by run towards us if ever you're like in a
situation where you're getting attacked a lot run towards
your your uh allies because they will be able to shoot the
bugs off yeah you're right you're so right yeah and
sometimes a grenade is faster than other stuff like
summoning i keep forgetting to throw my grenades okay that's
okay you'll trust me it's it's pretty overwhelming the first
time okay you're doing really good oh by the way don't worry
about the like how much time you'd love to use a stratagem
because then the airship will go out.
I'll be honest, I didn't even see a timer.
Now I feel stressed.
No, I'm just kidding.
No, no, no, you're fine.
Now I feel stressed and anxiety is quietly down every
second.
I could have lived without that knowledge.
That information?
Yeah.
I can't believe you would be this insensitive to my
feelings.
Sorry, it's just the Canadian in me.
Sorry.
It's just the Canadian that's coming out.
Is it too late now to say sorry?
Because I...
It's funny because that guy is more than just your body.
I'm missing your...
Clear landing zone.
They're very delicious.
I think we cleared it.
What the?
Yeah.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I think level three might be a little
too easy.
Yeah, you were like, get ready for a bunch of bugs and it
was...
kind of mid okay girl we'll put you on five god yeah mid mid
tarah i am pretty mid i'm not gonna lie i am the equivalent
of mid no i am the equivalent of here if i ever get if
people ever want to call me something like make fun of my
name they can call me mid press c made to fall home see
press c yeah then just go in oh okay nice oh look at you
girl I noticed she was stuck, so...
Makes first mission!
Yay!
We survived!
Yahoo!
I am impressed because when my first time didn't kill me
like 100 times on my first play and nobody killed each
other, this is amazing!
Yeah, it's amazing!
Being nice to first time player!
The night is young, Hena.
I'm full of dangers.
Uh-oh.
We got three stars.
We did everything.
Ooh!
Nice!
Yippee!
That's true, Mint.
You did kill me.
And yeah, Mint killed me.
Remember that.
I did?
That's fucked up, Dale.
How did I kill you?
Remember when you shot the barrel and I died?
Oh, that was me?
Yeah.
Ha ha ha, yeah.
You shot the barrel, Mint.
You told me to.
I was just being a good listener.
That Hell Divers is so much easier when we're not playing
with Zintra.
because she kills us all the time mint i remember saying
kill me every single time and there's so many times i'm not
even bloody just a little bit bloody i've seen some things
in my time okay mint with a 71 accuracy you have the highest
accuracy of all of us mint let's go
199 friendly damage see you know i told you i was good at
gun game pew pew pew pew pew oh yes you don't have it i know
i know oh my god there's this game yeah you do it because i
have the least amount of i'm teasing i'm teasing a game i
just immediately gunned for it i was so used to it i was
like oh it's not there anymore oh do i just return the ship
oh yeah i'm about to pick a harder mission okay you stay
here
a fun mission okay we're about to change it try her on nine
i don't even enjoy a beat i think i'm ready my friends put
me in level nine i have now a ptsd wait wait wait wait how
can i not change the difficulty in here in this window you
have to leave the world world and then be able to change oh
my god that's okay i'll i'll i want your blood on me you
know you can go back to the ice yeah we can yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you should see the difficulty yeah nice nice thank
you how do you evo b ah b oh b for bitches i just do this i
wait i do like a So do you see the acquisitions on your top?
Uh-huh.
So you press R and it shows you the different like battle
passes, but they're permanent.
So you can always get them.
Oh, nice.
So this is where you get your guns and ammo and stuff like
that.
So that's where we get most of our gear and stuff.
Like this one.
Yeah.
And you'll be able, as you keep playing with us, like
you'll, that's why I was doing all the side missions while
you guys were running around.
So that way we have more money to spend.
Mine.
Nice.
Money.
A rich man's world.
Nah, I like my impact grenades.
I don't want to switch them off.
Yeah, I like them a lot too.
And then every mission that we're doing is different.
So this one is a 15 minute mission.
Oh, it says clicking.
Usually when people get into that screen, people like to be
like, let's drop here.
And then they just spam everything.
It's just to be annoying.
I don't even know.
I've been doing that for instance at the beginning.
I infected all my friends with it.
She's been a little annoying since the beginning.
That's her haru.
Yeah.
Big kiss.
We can try robots after two minutes.
They are.
They are some.
The robots.
Robot time.
Oh no.
It's a robot.
Uh oh.
Are we killing?
It looks like.
I'm ready to kill.
I've never done this mission before, I think.
How do you see what the mission is?
Rescue.
Oh, yeah.
Press Q, and then you'll see.
Retrieve essential personnel.
Determinate advance has swarmed across this region, leaving
one of our top secret research stations surrounded by the
enemy.
Use your clearance to unlock the emergency bunker doors and
defend the facility staff as they enter to the evacuation
shuttle.
Oh, is this the one where you print scientists?
We create people?
Yeah.
You basically, like, you click a button and then the people
come out, so you just kind of print them.
It's great.
Oh.
This is the clone wars after all my love.
Here we go.
Wait, it's a little five.
Oh, sure.
Am I a clone?
Yeah!
You're a clone of yourself!
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah.
How do I use stims on people?
So you go to them and it says use stim.
Oh wow, that's handy.
But only when they're low health.
Oh yeah, speaking of stims, even if you have like, even like
if you tripped on a rock and have like the minimal like...
Why am I slowed?
Like for example, if you trip and have like a little damage
done to you, I always recommend stimming.
It's always important to have...
I'm always out here stimming, Haruka.
I'm fine.
But it's always good to use your...
your stim because it gives you once you stim you have like a
few seconds of immunity as well so I always stim even though
if I tripped on a rock and I'm like I have a boo-boo I just
stim that shit that's breach boo-boo fire in the hole I
didn't know you were an overwatch gamer I hate it here I
know she was junk rat honestly mint and junk rat do have a
of similarities what's that a junk rat is the character in
overwatch that says fire in the hall wait and that's just
like me yeah my little little australian rat i never played
what i scuttle around i'm like yeah overwatch is a pvp game
oh i used to like overwatch and overwatch one but i despise
overwatch why what happened what changed oh my god that's so
dramatic no i'm being on overwatch one was heaps better
overwatch 2 just completely what really pissed me off was
overwatch 2 entire premise of his existence was to do pve
story base then they canceled that and then all they did is
it's basically the same game but like we're gonna remove one
slot so instead of six it's five people to play like the
changes they've done overwatch 2 piss me the fuck off i hate
overwatch i used to play overwatch every day i used to love
overwatch guys i'm sorry we we this is it this tom howard if
you're listening i would love to get sponsored to watch the
fallout series please do not take haruka's words into your
heart no fallout this fall tv series is great i've been
watching a few we can't finish it i finished it i'll watch
too
You watched it, Hanya, did you play Fallout?
Yeah, I played Fallout.
Oh, I heard it's real good.
Yeah, I love it.
What are you watching on?
It's on Amazon.
Yeah.
You can watch?
You can watch the TV shows without knowing anything about
Overwatch.
Oh yeah, that is true.
That's true.
Fallout, Fallout, Fallout.
Oh!
fallout fallout fallout fallout lots of fallout in a
radioactive world but yeah that's why i don't like overwatch
mod and i'm so sorry if you like it that's just my opinion
how dare you have a different opinion than me also i mean
everything you said is valid you press g thank you I don't
think it works.
Oh, check your grenades at the bottom left.
Do you have zero out of four grenades?
Did you use all your grenades?
No, I have three.
Oh my goodness, there's a lot going on here.
Oh, wait, guys, I forgot this is only a 15-minute mission.
Oopsies, I'll come to you.
Oh, I was out here running around, but it's a 15-minute
mission.
Oh, wait, what are we supposed to be doing?
We have to go to the orange thing.
Orange thing.
I completely forgot.
I'll meet you guys there.
Are you okay?
Orange.
I got you, I got you.
Grenade!
I keep throwing in like terrible.
I thought you could aim it, so I was like, oh.
Yeah, I'm sort of.
You'll get the hang of it.
And then some grenades explode in a little bit.
Nice!
Ow!
My body.
Oh!
What just happened?
I think so...
Okay, so we have to score 30 type people.
I don't know what... I think the game lagged to me.
It said I was killed by Hena.
Oh.
Wait, what?
I killed...
No, way.
I think the game lagged.
There's no way that Hena would kill me.
I think the game is bugged.
The game is bugged.
Don't worry.
I think that's called copium.
It's been, um...
No, it's been killed by your urchin.
It's kind of precious, though.
People would pay a lot of money for that.
Exactly what I've always wanted.
Yeah, there we go.
Yeah, not gonna lie.
seen this mission before.
Where's my guy?
So over there, Mata, there will be like, I will teach you
the ways, though.
Yeah, I've never seen this mission before.
I think we just skipped past a seven pretty quickly.
So over here.
Oh, at the bottom, right?
The computer?
Yeah, there's this little fun.
You press it and three people come out.
And then you got to protect them.
It's the printing button.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll just start pressing.
He's like this way.
I'm printing.
Do not shoot the little people walking, by the way, you
guys.
Don't shoot the little people.
Okay, I'm gonna shoot them.
I'm gonna shoot them.
I'm gonna shoot them out.
Kill them out.
Demog and sweet liberty.
I think that's communism.
That's not very democratic of you.
Oh, Haru?
Yes.
Are you?
Where are you?
Because one of us needs to be on the end.
You're where?
I'm on the other computer.
Oh, because there's the bug.
The bugs are coming from here.
What's this?
Okay, girls, girls.
Come here, both of you.
You guys are gonna partner in here.
Girls, girls, girls.
Yeah, I'm- you're gonna press this button every time it's
available.
One of you presses the button.
One of you defends like near it.
And I'm gonna go defend at the other side of the- Oh my God,
little people!
Where's the button?
Kita, Kita, Kita.
Oh, this button, this button.
Yep, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
A key.
How do you know when it's available?
Lights up.
It'll- It'll blow.
Look at him running around.
We're in the box.
We can blow.
Oh my God, these people are gonna die.
These stupid little people.
You don't know how to play with a bug.
They're dumb little clones.
Fuck you.
Just anytime you have the button, just press it.
Anytime you can.
I'm going to punch the shit out of this guy.
It's a Rani.
Push the button.
I can buy eight people.
My children.
Yeah, you're a mother now.
Congrats.
Oh.
I'm not ready for this response, but it only created three.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's going to keep creating three.
So just keep.
Okay.
And Hado and I are going to depend on each side.
You guys can shit out six people at a time.
Yeah.
Wait, there's another computer?
Six people!
Well, no, no.
You stay at the one you're at.
Okay.
You keep doing the one you're at.
Oh, I see the other one.
Wait, should I go to it?
No, I got it.
No, I don't.
I keep pressing it when you can.
I'm doing the other one.
La la la la.
More people.
Come out, little scientist.
It's the hell divers!
Why do you run like that?
Come on.
Get him.
Shape!
Get in shape!
How many people do we need?
A lot.
18 out of 35.
Sorry, this mission is the worst.
Okay, okay.
That's alright.
We got this.
Come on, citizen.
I'm gonna get a diet freedom.
Anyone else wanna drink?
I would love a little sip of freedom.
Yeah.
Do you have the Dr. Pepper?
That's a very freedom.
Democratic drink.
No, it's just diet freedom.
Can I get a nukakola?
Oh, real hell divers!
Go, get, stop ogling.
Oh, my mana's stuck!
Never mind.
My favorite thing is that they go on top of the rock just to
get to where they are.
I didn't like the taste of freedom!
Freedom!
I hope you guys are...
Oh, it's not lit.
We're almost...
Keep printing, keep touching, keep doing.
I'm waiting, I'm waiting.
Okay, almost there, almost there, almost there.
Patience.
20, 30, I have 35.
It's a virtue I do not have.
We know.
This is, oh my machine gun.
Oh wow, that's a lot of things over there.
Oh my God, I'm right in front of the door, shit.
Oh shit.
Run!
It's okay, run, run, run, little man, just run through.
Run, little man, run!
I'm printing more men.
Printing more men, come on.
The mother of men.
Printing men, printing men.
Run my clones.
The mother of men.
Sons of the Patriots, genome soldiers.
Three more people coming now.
Run my little genome soldiers.
Oh my god, is that Metal Gear reference?
Oh my god.
Can't believe you just made a Metal Gear reference.
That's crazy.
I feel like I'm not doing enough.
Yeah, you're doing great.
You're doing the most important job of all.
Now we get the fuck out of here.
You're printing the little men.
Yay, we did it!
Oh, that's a big guy.
It's right in the middle.
Wait, have you done the...
Oh, God.
You can start this up over here, Mint.
Which one?
Where am I?
Yeah, sorry, this is over here.
Very annoying.
I regret picking it.
This thing?
No, do you see my little white arrow thingy?
Yeah, yeah.
Come to it.
Okay, I'm coming.
It's time for you to input the Konami code.
Oh, here.
Interact.
You got this.
Got it.
You're basically a soldier now, congrats.
Oh my god!
You have now evolved to a super citizen.
Oh!
Super citizen of...
Dwight, does that mean I have to pay super taxes or...
Yeah, you do.
Unfortunately, I cannot disclose this information, but good
luck.
Whoa, these are so awesome.
These, like, turrets.
Yeah, it's my turret.
Be careful, though.
It can still kill you, even though it's her turret.
Oh, just kidding.
Yep, be careful.
Also, I'm sorry, girls, I can't mute.
Thank you for the gifted.
Yay!
What's an anti-tank?
I really appreciate it.
Oh, wow.
It's a turd that hates tanks.
I'm joking.
Yeah, it hates it.
I think I just acquired it.
Don't shoot us with it.
Are you sure?
What does that do?
I think you should shoot us with it.
Are you sure?
That'd be really funny.
Do it!
I'm sure.
Oh!
I had a shield!
You suck it!
No!
I had a shield, Mint!
I had a shield!
My... my...
I'm gonna... You know what?
I'm gonna drop my hell pod right on your head.
Where are you?
Do it.
I'm right here.
I dropped on my dead body, actually.
You can grab the shield if you want, Mint.
Here.
No, no, no, it's okay.
It's okay.
It's gonna protect you from a... I should have given it to
you sooner.
My bad.
I forgot.
Don't worry about it.
I'll worry about it.
Get it twisted.
I worry.
Okay, these chargers, you see them?
The big guy with like the big pouch on his butt.
You gotta pop the little pouch on his butt.
He charges on you.
I don't see what you're talking about.
He's at the bottom there.
Hanya's attacking him.
I'm attacking something.
It's a bug with a big, big, big, big butt.
Got a big fat butt.
Gotta hit his butt.
I gotta hit his butt.
I'm just shooting.
The butt!
Oh, this guy!
Yeah, you see?
He's got a big butt.
Oh, reload.
Once you blow up the little ball on his butt, he dies like
three seconds after.
Weak.
Yeah, he's weak.
Why would you die once you're- Oh, someone shot me and
launched me into the fray?
That's cool.
Wait, what?
It wasn't me for real.
Be careful!
Be careful that you might die.
You might die.
Yeah!
Um, I'm okay.
I don't- Okay, guys, the ship is here if you want to go in.
How do I, uh, there we go.
Uh, I'm trying to get up.
My murder is girls.
It's time.
I can't believe I lived.
How did I survive that?
I don't know.
No.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, he's sorry.
Oh, there.
Oh, God.
I somehow got it.
Dun, dun, dun.
How did I live?
You're just too good at the game.
You're just, you're just a cracked game.
Like, so I, I got blown up by the bug and I flew to the bugs
and then I, there were There was rain of spiders and
everything.
It's crazy.
You fell into the ring of spiders?
We survived.
Survived, I am.
How you liking it so far?
It's so fun.
We, at one point, Haruka and I played this until like 8 in
the morning.
Because what happens is somebody will drop out and then
another person will come in.
And you just, the lobby changes every time and we just play
until 8 in the morning.
That's us.
That's the title of my ship.
It's the patriotism of patriotism.
I like that.
I think I'm the mother of battle.
The mother of battle.
My ship is called the Dawn of Eternity.
That's cute.
You are supposed to be badass!
I swear to God, Mint.
Cute.
I'm happy you're back, but fuck you.
yeah freak you too I can't believe this man SMH my head whoa
I'm screen no I'm not I was looking at you wait why are you
guys all green you would die I'm so haven't showered in two
days I'm clean mission coordinates lost another stupid
defend mission I'm getting worse you've always been worse
I'm getting worse though.
Can I get much worse than how I already am?
Get it twisted, Mint.
I'm twisted.
My brain is twisted.
She twisted.
Oh no.
Mint, every time I look at you, it makes me want to have
mint chocolate and I hate mint chocolate and this is all
your fault.
That, see, that's where it's like a brainwashing.
Are you trying to brainwash me to like something that I
hate?
Yeah.
Wait, you hate it?
Yeah, I don't like mint chocolate.
Bad taste.
Okay.
I never liked it.
What the fuck?
I never liked the chocolate mint.
Never ever ever.
I don't know, just the taste, it just feels too strong in my
mouth.
I'm like, ah.
I think when I was a kid, I liked it, but as I grow up, I
just like enjoyed different taste, but I don't hate it, I
guess.
That's my girl.
Yeah.
I mean, I like peppermint, but I don't, maybe, you know
what?
Maybe I should try mint chocolate now.
Yeah.
I should try it down.
What's it called?
The, um, the ones that, that have this dark chocolate and
the white chocolate like the or not white chocolate the
white mint inside i think it's after eight oh the peppermint
patties oh never mind oh it's so good they are peppermint
patties let me yeah they're so yummy isn't that girl scout
ones no oh these things oh um those are i don't think i've
ever had them those are mints gosh matara those are just
those are mints the the girl scout ones oh i'm ready sorry
you know what maybe i should try these three one day and
i'll message you going they're still shit mint they're still
really shit but i did it for you they still suck yes please
report back to me Every year you should set a date for April
23rd where you try them and then you message Mint and go
still sucks.
April 23rd?
I'm sorry.
That's not, wait, oh I was thinking of 33rd.
I was like, there's no, there is no 23rd.
What if I just made a entire documentary of me trying out
mint chocolate just for you?
You're like, hi guys, I'm here to go.
We're gonna get you, I'm gonna send you a bunch of mint
chocolates and then you can just try them all and you can
decide.
Grab the backpack.
That's a really good idea.
I'm actually so down to this.
I'll leave the backpack for you.
Where?
Give me all your favorite bin chocolates.
And that'd be a fun collab to do actually.
Holy shit.
Actually, I'm so down to it.
Oh, wait.
Did they have a matcha flavor in the ice cream?
Or is that only Japan thing?
We do a little bit.
A little bit, but it's not as popular here.
Mm-hmm.
It's way more popular in Japan.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And the matcha in Japan is so good.
I never left my house.
what that's like well you you and henya are a little two
hiki commodities yeah we never go outside no it's just
ironic considering my background yeah outside is overrated
outside is scary don't go outside oh i think no outside i
don't remember yeah welcome to the welcome to the team
have to load the little sea missiles.
All right, let's do this.
Let's not throw a grenade for this one, because we'll get
more points if we don't actually do it.
What do you mean more points?
We get more points for us.
Oh, that's a big, oh, that's his butt.
That's his butt.
Wait, how do I get your butt?
Get your butt, get your butt.
That was where the thingy went in.
Oh, no, I want to see your butt.
No.
Give me your butt.
There it is.
Oh.
She's staying.
Oh my god.
Ah!
I
got killed by Henya.
I think the game glitched again.
I said I got killed by Henya again.
Mata, can you revive all of us?
Because Henya killed us all?
Yeah, everybody!
I'm sorry.
Alright, girls.
Make yourselves useful.
Grab an artillery missile and load him in.
You can't tell me what to do.
Load him in.
Stuff.
What's this?
Go get your stuff.
Wait, where's my stuff?
You can see it on the map.
Oh yeah, yeah.
It's just that I was the only one alive.
So I'm the only one that can summon you guys back.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go get my stuff.
Yeah, you can go get your stuff.
No, I'm- You can see it on the map.
You can follow them.
These dogs are pissing me off.
You sons of bitches.
These bugs were made for walking.
Ah, this is what they- Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ah, this is what I do.
The drop method.
Is this how you- What is this?
Walk on.
How is that actually faster?
What the heck?
Where is my stuff?
Did I pass it or?
Is that my stuff?
Oh, it's this way.
This is kind of...
This is like...
This is speedrunner strat.
She's speedrunning?
It's because I didn't know how to speedrun a mission, but
that's because I never do the missions.
I always bring Haruka who always does the missions.
Yeah!
Oh!
Are you okay?
You're okay.
Yeah, I broke my screen.
Watch this, man.
Watch this.
Uh-huh.
Dead.
Whoa.
Is this the butt guy or am I crazy?
Yeah, that's the butt guy.
Okay.
But if you have...
Charger, charger.
So your weapon, if you shoot at it, do you see these sparks
coming out of it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That means your IMO is not penetrating.
I noticed that.
So you have to hit his ass.
But for me, who has the, what I like to call the croissant
cannon, I buy a shoot at the right angle.
I can one shot of it and kill him instantly.
I call the croissant cannon, but I call it the croissant
cannon, and it's...
Oh, my stuff is over here.
Oh, my stuff is over there.
You know what?
Let's just leave it alone.
No, go get your stuff.
Go get your shield pack.
There's a lot of guys over there.
They'll help you.
You guys are fun.
Oh, look guys.
They're dead.
they're dead all the guys are dead it's a woman's only game
no men here oh exactly i actually don't even know where my
stuff is right here oh right here you're right yeah that one
that one thanks my shield is back now you won't die i'm
coming back i'm coming back before though that's kind of
crazy how that works so henya's eagle also broke the illegal
turn the the transmitter tower but if you actually do it
legitimately you get more points so I was going to see that
was the case oh so Hania did it illegitimately yeah but it's
okay I didn't realize I was so far on the map wait did I
fuck up no no we just get less points but that's it oh how
nice I got rid of the nest good job girlies the bug nest by
the way like you'll see them in the future you gotta throw
little grenades in them oh yes I remember them from the
tutorial different so i don't know what they look like in
the real world yeah because i keep killing them in the real
world in the real i only know the in the mission the
tutorial they haven't trained me for the real world i'll
stop um i'll stop giving help from now on if you have
questions feel free to ask it's just that at first when i
first played nobody explained anything to me and i had a
really hard time streaming and following along no you're
good did i do a bad job explaining to My first games wasn't
with you, baby.
Oh, right, right, right.
And again, it's absolutely not, you know, a criticism.
I played with some lovely people who were great.
Uh, boy.
Yes.
Oh, you need some help?
I got you, baby girl.
Run.
I'm trying to run.
Oh, I'm running.
I'm running.
It sounds like a song.
I'm trying to run.
Be nice.
I don't need the balls.
I try to run.
Oh, baby.
Oh, oh, oh, I need to reload.
Hey, you better move.
No, no, no, I have to run.
I'm opening up my eyes.
This thing's crazy, this beam.
I know, you get it at level 20.
I was so happy when I finally got mine.
I, like, I grind a little bit.
It's like a badge of honor.
It is.
Because it does take a little while, even if you play the
game a lot.
I'd say, still tell her about holding R.
you are zoomed in on your gun and press middle button it
gives you like the extra scope which i didn't find out until
like two weeks ago i didn't know i didn't find out until two
weeks ago wait how do you shoot with what like wait so let's
say you're shooting your gun right you're aiming with right
mouse and then click middle mouse isn't that crazy you can
do that with every gun oh my god i didn't know that i didn't
know that also also another one hold r you can change the
speed i what hold r you hold r on your gun and then what i
believe i can't exactly remember how to switch between the
two but like for my sickle i'm shooting a hundred m per
minute oh my god hundred bullets per minute is that the
fastest because i only want to shoot faster not slower Yeah,
right?
Higher the number faster it is.
And how do you get the number up?
It depends if it's sideways.
I think you use your scroll wheel, but I believe it's
like...
Oh, it's the sideways it means it's gonna go faster.
I don't know if I... Which way I like more.
No, I'm trying to remember the patrol.
No, it's fine.
Try not to worry about it.
I don't want to...
Explosive barrel.
I got you, Queen.
Oh!
Oh, there's all the guys over there.
what's this note oh good job wait nice i have like no
bullets at all uh oh wait i can do a uh resupply yeah
resupply yeah okay and then if you see these uh wait wait
wait don't open it h4 once nick gets here i want her to see
this and open it so that she sees what it looks like okay
may i take stim oh no yeah yeah you can take the stim thank
you take take take is it the friendship door no i want her
to see what it's like when you um when there's the little
glowy stuff on the map what come towards me do you see come
come here do you see this big glowy thing where i'm here
where are you and oh i'm so this can sometimes have extra
guns or it can have like super credits whoa it has uh what
is that reposition slips that's our the stuff that you need
to level up oh so just if you see a shiny spot it's like a
little treasure always try to pick it up charger a charger
no wait is that a charger left Left or dead?
Charger!
Left or dead, too.
I want to play that game again.
Yeah!
What about Barber's play?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah!
Oh, yeah!
I don't think I've, uh, I played it, I think, only once,
like, a year ago.
Oh, God.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, wait, am I okay?
Oh, no, I'm not okay.
I would, I would avoid his, uh...
His, uh, everything?
Yeah, you can, like, uh, press off to get out of his attack.
Oh, I definitely did.
Yeah, I did that.
Oh, nice.
The shield also will absorb, I think, like, one damage from
him, but I'm not sure if it's, like, a full.
Oh, sorry, I shot you in the shield.
I got him.
Good job.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
We have for some guns if you hold R, you can change the
speed of it, and I can't...
Oh, here we go.
That's crazy.
Okay.
So if the bar is up on the gun, you scroll your wheel up to
change oh oh so now i'm used to seeing like one little bug
mess oh wait there's a bug oh oh yeah mint mint mint i'll
let you come mint you have to shoot your grenade inside the
hole okay you're gonna come here stand here but like you
have to shoot it in good job i did shoot it in yeah sorry
sorry it's just i'm using the grenades that explode
immediately so i forget that like regular grenades take a
while to pop up Sorry.
No, you're okay.
Because mine pops like right away.
This is great.
Oh my god, he was so cute right in my face.
I can do that by the way.
I have the same flaws.
Here, now that I'm getting chased by 40,000 dogs, I could
teach you what I was trying to teach you, Mata.
Sorry?
I could teach you what I was trying to teach you without
being chased.
So stop moving and then hold R.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, no, I saw what it looks like.
Thank you, thank you.
It's like you hold R and then it like switches.
up to change your speed wait oh i'm changing things i don't
know what i'm doing so 100 means faster right yes and you
move your swivel just up to change the speed so right now
you see how oh i see i see it so my default is i was just
shooting slow no 100 is the no 100 is the fastest people are
saying that's range oh that's the scope of the gun oh it
depends on some gun sometimes some My chap said right click
is speed Oh, I have a Oh, there's a flashlight Oh, that's
the scope Okay, so every gun is a little different
apparently Okay
I genuinely
I genuinely had no idea I'm still I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
Um, I'm gonna request reinforcement.
I'm so sorry.
So for some guns, holding R changes the scope, and some
guns, like the machine gun, changes the speed of how you do
it.
Democracy is landing.
Wait, where's our stuff?
You can see it on the map.
That was so fucking funny though.
I'm so sorry.
Wait.
The backpack is there if you want it.
Yeah.
That's true.
Some guns are different.
Just holding R changes your settings.
This is yours.
Yeah.
Oh.
I know.
El Diver.
My knife is right here too.
Your machine gun.
Oh, my machine gun.
Thank you.
You guys are so cute.
Kawaii.
No, you.
Oh no, no big guy.
I guess it would be like, Oh no, are you a traitor?
Wait, are you a filthy traitor?
Don't get out of the combat zone.
How do I get back to the combat zone?
You have to run back to the combat zone!
That's the way!
I'm back on that tree!
I'm not a traitor!
I'm democratic!
I cannot believe- I think the game glitched again.
I said I was killed by HU wedding.
Wait, what?
I think the game is glitched.
It was really glitched.
I think once again, you're coping.
Wait, I'm going to kill her this time!
Hanya, you're a murderer.
Hanya is a tiny little baby murderer.
Dude, oh, wait.
I was going to do the shark song, but you're on the YouTube,
so we're going to be careful not to say that.
What song?
I was going to say baby murderer.
Oh, I think it's okay.
It's not, you know, it's going to be like, oh, that
definitely can't be the original.
It sounds like an old hag saying it's not like a different
baby.
Oh, so...
So this is just an ignorant...
question my person you can't like do coming in coming in hot
little singing of songs on you wait not even the humming no
you can i think i think it's okay the charger look different
than before it does look a little different he does i think
you never played it before this guy oh is he not the butt
man yeah he's the butt man but he looks a little different
he looks more armored he also is taking oh it is a different
he's taking a ton of yeah it's like a box he's a box he's
not He's a boss man.
He's a boss man.
Mr. Buttman.
Gun dancer.
Bring me a dream.
Da-da-da-da.
Is he still alive?
Die already.
How is he alive without his butt?
I've never seen him before.
Stop camping.
He's obsessed with me.
I know why.
But I can't.
Yeah, he's like still crawling.
What the heck?
I've never seen one last so long.
Hey.
He's down.
Nice!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Guys, I have a bad feeling.
Yep, we're gonna get bugged.
Sorry.
We're gonna get bugged.
I let them call it.
My bad.
Watch out.
I'm gonna throw and you go at it.
I already threw one.
Hee.
All the way over here, Dayo.
Oh, there we go.
Where I just pinged.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's going.
Because this looks like an escort citizen victim.
I'm going to which planet is this.
This is the defense planet, the one that we have in the
mission.
I am coming.
I'm coming, too.
Nice.
Oh, you're stupid robot.
It's okay.
I had my shield.
Yeah, the robot, the little robot doesn't discriminate.
The little robot does not discriminate.
It's true.
He kills anybody.
I'm running.
Nice use of the little eagles.
Was that you, Min?
No, I don't have eagles.
Oh, you haven't unlocked them yet.
I'll show you where to unlock them after this game.
Can you guys remind me?
Yep.
Hey, Ma, make sure you tell Min about the eagles,
stratagems.
Oh, yeah, I will.
Yeah, don't forget about it, though.
Actually, Haruka, you can tell her about it.
Because you can probably teach her how to aim better than I
can aim.
Yeah, I'll help you.
I'll be with you.
I'll be your buddy, Matal.
I just kind of say, fuck it, we ball and hope for the best
sometimes.
Yeah, come on.
I'm here.
Haruka, we're in polite society.
Mint is a polite little one.
She's on the YouTube.
We can't be swearing like this.
What?
I'm part of a freedom society, actually.
A managed democratic society.
Can I say fuck, then?
If anything, you're unmanaged.
Wait, bitch, so does that mean I can say fuck now?
Oh, goddamn.
She's going in.
Thank you, Min.
I can say fuck now.
No, don't say thanks to me.
Say thanks to Neil.
Huh?
Thank you.
You always make sure to resupply since you have a gun with
bullets.
If you ever see bullets on the ground.
Have a gun with bullets.
Well, it's because mine, mine all don't have bullets.
Look at you fancy pants.
I know.
I did it because, okay, see the one, one of them is like
spitting something.
He's like farting into the, oh, too late.
I didn't see.
It's all right.
It's okay.
We specialize.
Realize.
She believes.
Oh no.
I hate the butt man.
It's okay.
I got him.
Oh, they're always obsessed with me.
Oh my god, it's because you smell so minty.
So cute.
Let me kill the little bugs.
This always happens at picnics.
The bugs come after me mode.
Really?
Oh, you're gonna hate me.
They never come after me.
oh hello i the little guys are so annoying like they think
they're a big deal but they they just suck they're like two
walls little bugs and in big numbers little bugs big
adventures help help help divers how divers who are you
gonna call help divers my mom
Busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting.
Good job.
I know.
I can do this one.
Wait.
Do you need some bullets, Vint?
Maybe.
I'm gonna grab some.
Yeah.
What's this?
That's, you always feel like you run out of bullets until
you kind of start learning where to look for bullets and
grenades.
He he.
Nades here.
here hold on honey yeah uh this is ssd drawing i'll give you
a shield here oh oh thanks also mint i'm sorry thank you for
the 20 gifted if i could so let me can mint get 20 gifted
too i can't be the one thank you thank you how about 21
gifted can anybody has 21 gifted for mint going once wait i
forgot youtube's doing the gifted thing now yeah yeah it's
been for a while i remember when youtube didn't do that now
okay she's an original thank you so much i remember
pepperidge farm remembers pepperidge farm remembers all
right oh put that ssd into the thingy henya they're doing
the main quest into the hole i'll see if you got a little
side quest here i'm just following you i wish you had a look
yeah i see if you have full grenades if not pick up these
grenades don't get on fire no i'm following grenades and
then these are samples by the way
Oh.
Busting made me feel good.
There's usually more than one.
There's usually like two or three samples.
So I'm just looking to see.
Okay.
But I think here there was only one.
Busting.
Sometimes, you know, she'll come here and say stuff.
And I'm like, ah, gotta let her live her best life.
I love that for her.
I'm happy.
Yay.
oh my gosh thank you for the gifts and you guys thank you
the game master does not like how fast we're progressing to
mint 22 gifted subs going once we're fine we're fine 22
gifted subs going we're fine take this take this charge yeah
and then this final mission is like right near where we're
extracting okay let's see what's up here no no up here I'm
fine.
I'm just following you.
Sorry.
Yeah, I'm always trying to, like, double-check around
because I'm always looking for samples and stuff.
Stop the imp.
There's an extra gun here, too, if you have.
Another gun?
There we go.
But you already have a machine gun, I think.
Yeah, I do.
Assholes.
When you summon things, dude, does it cost money?
Summon what things?
Like, if I have to summon ammo and stuff, does it cost
money?
Nope.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's just that we all share a pool of some.
So, you have, like, you see the stratagems that I use there,
the eagle?
That I have limited amount of those but then they resupply
they go on cool down same for your gun like your gun is free
but it has a cool down okay you can only summon it like
three or four times in a game which is why when you die it's
nice to go back to your old gun and pick it up yeah okay
that makes sense you got like 300 gifted why not 400 huh we
gotta go back in the back you go back where i could stay
here and do the bug nest and then activate there's uh i
don't I'll go.
I'll stay.
You know what?
I'll go by myself.
Yeah, I'll- I'll stay.
I was gonna go, but if we're...
You can do whatever.
I just want to clear the little bug mess so we get more
experience.
At least Hania's coming with me.
Okay, then I'll come with you.
I'm coming!
I'm coming.
I'm gonna...
I'm a little slow, but I'm gonna...
Are you coming with us, Minka?
Yeah.
Okay, I'll wait.
I'll get you.
No, no, you don't have to wait.
I'm waiting.
what did i do okay we're waiting oh no why did that shoot
him no oh my god i activated a bug breach
we're getting comfortable here hey mint oh wow we haven't
waiting for you sorry it took so long kept you waiting bro
there we go oh oh oh it's a dog while now well we well we
haven't seen a ton of three years we're gonna go up we're
gonna go we're gonna go a little bit too close better way to
get back to knowing each other than you know collaborating
democracy democracy i love liberty sweet liberty sweet
liberty all right i'm gonna give myself a resupply so i can
build my pack pack okay i'm gonna climb this rock maybe you
shouldn't climb up that So you're really close to that.
Ouch!
Oh, you little shit back!
Uh-oh.
I gotta run!
I'm okay.
Now watch this.
And then boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
And I can give you...
Oh, come here, come here, come here, come here!
Here you go.
Oh, thank you, Haru!
There you go.
Now everyone is beefed up.
Woohoo!
Ready to go.
I have the music turned off in this game when my music set
playing, so this is a very, very relaxing stroll for me.
it's all quiet and shit and i'm just like oh this is so
peaceful you know hanging out with my friends yeah mada
might be dying but it's okay no no no no i'm fine i'm fine
i'm fine are you good i'm doing great i activated the blood
nest and i'm running back swim oh taking a dive oh you got
rid of the drown genuinely can you actually yeah you can
probably because basically your armor in the lore is really
heavy oh so you'll drown oh yeah yep you'll die i die from
many times oh kenya have you been to fujikyu yeah i have
what's your favorite favorite um roller coaster thing to do
there it's crazy that's the name of it though yeah so what
is it what is it do what is the attraction so usually when
you go on the roller coaster you have a place to put your
but on that one it's like you're in the midair so you have
to take off your shoes yeah and you're flying around in the
midair and then they're doing a spinning good 30 60 degree
and a lot of stuff the seats that's the stuff i don't like
the seats spin too it's real it's really crazy i also like
kujiyama too no it wasn't so bad for me fine and what's
fujiyama like i think it's a tallest one in the japan yeah
oh is it like the proper roller coaster you go up you go
down yeah yeah yeah there's one there's one or at the top
you get to see like a good view of mount fuji yeah i like
that i like that if you're wearing glasses you have to take
it off yeah yeah no i don't food food it's fine it's fine oh
i think they have they have a like a little i don't know if
they have a restaurant because i never been to but uh they
got a little like a market thingy going on outside so can
just like get the some cheap food for 100 yen or one again i
feel like they have that everywhere right the little street
oh that's not so good or they got the combini really cool so
we just go combini and get some stuff and we just ready to
go back on the roller coaster that's what i do it's because
uh in in not in japan and like other countries usually the
whenever you go into the amusement park you can't come out
so they make you curious so that you order expensive food
what i've always been able to you can go back out really i
guess that's maybe just uh north like these canadian things
because they oh my goodness there's usually no food near it
so you basically have to eat over over christ dude there
wait really yeah but they let you leave because they'll
sometimes like stamp your thing right yeah they give you a
little stamp there's no on your body oh yeah that's true for
a lot there's not even a convenient there's usually no food
nearby so that way you kind of have to buy food there which
is pretty expensive right oh there's a little man there's a
little man got a mush got a mush okay i think it's a bit
yeah there you go hi man hi man oh can i punch these are my
clothes i punched the man don't punch my people come here
little guy give me your give me your lunch money idiot oh my
god wow you've changed You came back from your graduation.
You changed.
Oh, there's there going after the little men.
Oh no, not the little men!
I can't pierce him.
Imagine being a little mad in the world.
The bugs are coming after you.
The little ghosts are coming after you.
Everyone's coming after you.
Stop it.
Stop attacking me, you stupid little guy.
Uh oh.
I can't get your butt.
Oh, I almost.
Oh, I killed him.
Good job.
You almost got me.
Watch this.
Oh, yeah.
watching watch out watch out for the little men I'm okay
doing amazing I'm gonna go create more men oh we lost three
oh I require more vest oh watch out mint I'm watching oh
last reload was I mean, it means that's your last reload,
baby.
It's a fire one.
Oh, I have to switch.
He's going to die right now.
There we go.
10 minutes
remaining.
Don't worry.
We need, like, two more.
We only got 10 minutes to kill the world.
And then as soon as you guys are done, I'll start acting.
waiting for the teleporter back home.
Watch out, little men.
Keep running.
Watch out, Steve.
Matata has the same bug build as me.
Are you also big-breasted and big-hipped?
And six-clawed?
Let's go.
I like how you...
I like how you had to mention the big-breasted part.
Yeah, you know what, they're like...
I went to your Twitter to see, like...
Yeah, big breasts?
Yeah, I saw big breasts on your fucking Twitter banner.
Uh-huh.
Go on.
What do you mean, huh?
I don't know what that was all about.
Now you got mince attention.
and you just have to mention big breasts and I gotta be
polite when she's over here sorry how to go for interrupting
what were you saying so you went to see big breasts and on
your Twitter banner I want to know what the hell is that
like though we need to add henya that initial Twitter banner
it should be like me's and Trey and henya wait are you
talking about that picture yep you know exactly what picture
I'm talking about what the heck now Do we need more men?
No, we're all good.
We just need to go home now.
Oh, okay.
Alright, um...
I'm allergic to men now, so I'm going home.
Which, what does it look like?
What does the go home look like?
It's where I am.
Come to where...
You see that light, the blue light going to the sky.
Oh, yes, that's right.
That one.
You can also press tab and you see that orange icon that has
an arrow going up to the stone.
Yeah.
That's the extraction point.
I can't start it right now because I got too many bugs
around me, but I'll start it in just a minute oh hey guys i
found a friendship door i want to come friendship door mint
do you want to come open this door with me what what i'd be
honored i'd be honored if you open it with me here oh gosh
i'm out of stamina this is the ritual to be like welcome
back friendship door oh okay
Oh shit, we might have got some cool stuff.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
We got a sample and...
What's that?
What is it?
A star wall.
And some stims.
Can I try that?
That's a gun.
A little bit of help soon, please.
Oh, you're a gamer.
You got this.
We'll take our time.
I'm just gonna take a leisurely stall.
Yeah, yeah, Mata.
Like, a people like you have a big mobile.
I don't think I have like zero stims.
You got the big boba.
Oh, oh, I see.
I see.
My boba don't have stim packs.
They're filled with mommos.
That's where I hide my mommos before I eat them.
I'm pretty sure you hide some stim pack inside.
You got this.
No, I hide my mommos before I eat them.
How do I get the other packs?
Oh, I got some samples.
Samples.
Beautiful mint.
I, I, I, I.
Wait, how do I get around there?
Uh oh.
Uh, just over here.
Oh, I see it.
Thanks.
I got you, fam.
Thanks, fam.
I was in trouble.
Love you.
I thought you were big.
Take my ego!
Yay!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Henya!
I would think that was personal if I didn't know you a
little better, Henya.
No.
You didn't die.
You're fine.
I didn't die yet.
The night is young, Henya.
Anything can happen.
It's full of...
You didn't die.
That's important.
That's important, Daniel.
I mean, we can just...
Watch us from afar if you want.
The knight is young and killed with Loba.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Yeah.
She's a little...
Watch up on your right.
Freak!
I'm a little freak!
Yeah, you are.
I want your blood on me!
Yep.
The smaller they are, the more...
The closer they are to hell.
Yeah, there we go.
That's definitely not me.
That's definitely not me, then.
Oh, Henny, pretty small and pretty crazy.
Hang on, I think you're fucked up like the rest of us.
Not as much as you!
Um, what do you mean?
Nah, not as much as you.
I don't know, I might have killed a few things in my day.
Hara, you're the most toxic Canadian I ever see it.
Yes.
It's not gonna hit us, you know.
I know.
I put it over there, though.
Oh, okay.
Hara, Hara, Hara.
You're the most toxic Canadian I ever see.
I've seen it before, so you...
That's an honor.
Because there's not a lot of us in this world anymore.
We Canadians are going extinct.
Canadians are going extinct.
It's true.
There's barely any Canadians left.
Every 10 Americans I meet online, I see one Canadian, and we
all go far out because we never meet a Canadian online.
It's true.
I feel like there's so many Canadian V-Tubers.
There are.
Yeah, they are.
There's so many.
Yeah, for us, Canadians, we can't...
Okay.
I don't know how to explain for us Canadians.
see each other ever oh wait wait can you tell by their how
they talk can you tell they're a canadian or american or
stuff like that can you tell uh no oh sometimes because
because we've been so critically online that our accent gets
hidden away it does oh i see it it only happens with some
words like sorry beg tag bagel bagel and bagel i say bagel
bagel bagel what is it What is the Canadian way of saying
bagel?
Bagel.
It's bagel.
Sweet Liberty.
My leg!
My gai.
I feel really patriotic.
Right?
This game just brings out the patriotism.
My gai has survived three missions and it's so fucking
dirty.
Holy shit he needs a bang.
Nice.
I am so covered by blood.
Hadoo, can you show her where to buy stratagems and stuff?
Minto!
And where to buy everything.
I have to pee.
Okay.
I trust you guys.
Hi!
Minto over here under.
It's this computer thing.
You press E to ship management.
Okay.
And then you see...
Go to stratagems.
Uh, hold on.
And then ship module.
This is where you get...
So on the top, this is where you see all your samples, all
your requisition slips, and then the blue icon is your super
samples, right?
And so you this is where you get all your stratagems Which
you need all the requisites and slips for But the ship
module if you go here This is where you can unlock things
for your ship Which helps enhance your stratagems that you
use Oh I can't get anything but that's okay If you play this
game a lot we'll be grinding And get you so many samples and
your ship will be Yeah Yeah Yeah yeah well yeah that's that
welcome thank you for watching my tutorial uh make sure to
like and subscribe bye i could get a sniper rifle yeah whoa
wait against light vehicle armor so not the but i mean you
could do for bugs but it's more so if they have penetration
armor on let's i said the but the butt the butt oh there's
wait that you the anti-tank that's the thing that will blow
up the butt yeah blow up the butt what is this finding nemo
i kind of want the rifle though it's up to you the best part
is exploring sniper sniper oh i love being a sniper too it's
one of my favorites yeah it's so fun i think i haven't tried
it yet but i'm at the sniper in every game so I try.
I try.
There's more if you scroll.
Oh, there is.
Oh, cat.
Oh, the...
The eagle.
Strike and die.
Eagle.
Do you guys do the eagles?
What?
Yeah, I use the eagles a lot.
I use the eagle airstrike.
It's the one that I use.
Me too.
But I got a 5 kilogram ton bomb.
yeah you have that one and I think you also use the cluster
bomb the cluster bomb oh yeah it's when you throw and it's a
cluster and while your airstrike goes in a straight line
where you throw oh yeah oh cute oh what's happening we eagle
airstrike an eagle never misses Eagle never misses.
But I, it misses.
Oh.
But it never misses.
Yeah, it never misses.
It's not them missing, it's us missing.
I, okay, hold on.
What's worse, them or us?
Uh, because we're...
Wrong, man.
No eagle misses.
Oh!
Yeah!
If it misses, it's the government's fault.
The government!
Yeah!
You can get the eagle if you want.
I like the eagle.
I don't know.
I like eagle too.
I have like a bomb thing, but I haven't used it because I'm
bad about remembering to use it.
Well, you get used to it.
Yeah.
Maybe I will get the rifle.
It's up to you.
The best part is that experimenting isn't having fun.
get the sniper then be disappointed why is it disappointment
well it's a shitty gun oh the the material rifle i'm looking
at your stream the material rifle um yeah it's a shit gun oh
oh wait the sniper is good sad oh it's good now hi i forget
it when shooting big bonds
Oh, Henya, I need your advice.
What is it?
A friend and I disagree on this.
When I go to maid cafes with this friend, I will say, I
should do to the maids.
And they love it.
And my friend says it's embarrassing.
What do you think?
Well, the thing is, I never really go outside.
I never went to the makeup, so I don't know how to interact
with them.
But do you think it is embarrassing if I say...
Nah!
Nah, people love it.
Grude.
They love it.
I'm telling you, they love it.
They light up, or they're too polite to say otherwise, but
they love it.
No, love it.
I'll tell my friend what you said.
my friend.
I'll let her know.
You tell her that she's wrong, the deadly wrong.
Can I tell her?
She's stinky and wrong.
Why do I have a feeling that the friend you're talking about
is in this call right now?
How do I...
That's crazy.
Oh, purchase.
No, no way.
No way.
That friend is here.
No, not at all.
That would be so awful.
Yeah, I know.
That person probably sucks so much.
Wait.
I know.
I need to get into the mission.
Buh.
I did it.
Nice deal!
It's open.
Yeah, they probably suck.
I'm just looking at Min's face and she has a smiley eyes
right now.
Well, are you looking at my face, Haruka?
Huh?
You want to kiss it or something?
What do you want?
Yeah, I missed it.
It's been, what, three years?
I've been seeing your face for three years!
I'm lonely.
I'm so mad.
Honestly, I could have gone a bit more time without seeing
your face, but here we are.
That's fucked.
It's your fault.
I'm here.
What?
I don't even understand where I screwed up in my summoning
ritual.
I have no idea.
It is your fault.
It's because you were you.
It's because you just did your own thing.
You're a screw up.
That's just the natural part.
How the fuck?
You sound just like my mom.
Oh, sorry.
My Okasan says the same thing.
My Okan.
Wah, wah, wah.
I love that song.
The song they were seeing earlier.
Oh, he mean, Rhapsody?
Yes.
It is.
Okay, so I have not played this before.
Whoa.
Oh, is it a siege?
Okay, we have to go.
go in and we have to defend the siege.
Defend the siege.
Over here.
Is Mint not streaming on Twitch?
Press exclamation mark Mint.
It'll get you to her YouTube channel.
Sorry, I only stream on YouTube.
But if you ever watch YouTube streamers, how do we get in to
this building?
I'm going over here.
I'm here.
How do I get in?
Over here.
We have to like go in up top.
Okay.
I'm following you.
look at i'm not even sure i'm going the right way there
should be an opening around there if you look in the map so
we're oh my god i think we went i'm so sorry i dropped us at
the completely wrong place it's okay i'm so sorry i can't
believe you would do this how dare you how dare you how dare
you i meant we're um the mission's gonna start also um in
the main missions you just have to complete the main
mission.
Even if everybody dies and the timer runs out, as long as
you complete the main mission, you'll still get the score.
Come in.
Oh, there it is.
Some doors to close.
Come in.
Okay, wait.
I'm sorry.
We're still running.
There's no, no.
I'm out of stamina.
Just keep running.
Just keep swimming.
There's a bug breach.
Hiya, do you think there is a bug breach?
We know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to put a Gatling cannon there.
careful just run just run just run just run just run and
then we're gonna i'm running and then where do we close the
door is this where we close the door yeah just go in first
and close the door we run in first and then close it yeah
okay are you i think they're coming in oh oh okay oh don't
worry i gotta okay and now they're gonna attack the door so
we gotta okay oh it's like a defense tower right yeah yeah
yeah it's a new mission mode that they added oh Okay.
All right.
Manta, go down here.
Oh, yeah.
I'm going to go.
I'm going to close this other door too.
Oh, hello.
And then we shoot them from up top.
Nice.
If you guys want to come in over here, you guys can.
Yeah.
I'm coming in.
I'm throwing the bomb.
Do it.
Click.
Where's a good place?
Oh, they broke the door because we weren't defending it.
Oh.
Oh, be careful.
Oh my goodness.
How do I use this thing?
It's okay.
We'll be fine.
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
I summoned you.
I got you.
I'm shooting a bug.
I really did summon us to the wrong place.
My bad.
No, it's out of.
Uh, how do I get out of this thing?
Uh, uh, wait.
Oh, no.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Okay, guys.
You have to launch the rockets.
It looks like.
Oh, we have to actually.
Uh-oh.
How do I get off the rocket?
We can also...
E?
Oh, E.
Thanks.
Thanks, chat.
We can also fall back, by the way.
If some of these are open, we can fall back.
Matara killed me, so...
I don't know what she's talking about.
I have the facts.
Oh, it doesn't automatically.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Don't know what she's talking about.
Oh, I spawn inside of a man.
Holding dollar.
Oh, my God, you're just like my momos.
That's how they are born.
Oh, I should have brought tourists.
I actually don't know what the mission is.
Oh, hello.
Oh, they closed the door on us, but it's okay.
It's okay.
They don't love us.
It's fine.
Hey, I wouldn't need her if I was them.
Yeah, never come back here.
I don't want to see your face anymore.
We can also open it from our side.
Tascado!
How does that feel, Mint?
Your ocean just told you you just got gone.
I absolutely love it.
What the fuck?
Call me gross!
Call me stinky gross and disgusting.
Mint, I don't know you're a massacist.
Yeah, it's one of my, you know, the M and Mint stands for.
M, M, M, M, S, S.
Uh, okay.
I am doing a Gatling turn.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I put my Gatling turn, man.
Okay.
Eagle.
I hope my Gatling is activated.
Watch out!
Oh!
Right?
Did I screw it up?
Did I screw up my Gatling?
I think it died.
I think it got exploded.
Yeah, I could only screw it up.
It had no bullets, though.
It had no bullets.
What, didn't?
The thing.
I need my bullets!
More bullets!
I need more bullets!
I'm going to go up here and I'm going to fight.
Watch out for my laser, um, Fanta.
Good job, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ooh.
Wow, it's just like, oh, wait, I can also use lazy or not
lazy.
I have an evil.
Yeah, you can use it.
Wait until they start coming in.
Wait until you see like that.
Look at you, you're an original.
I mean, a natural.
I'm a natural.
See, like, over there, I'm an original.
Oh, that is smart.
Original.
So if I...
These are the genius as evil as you.
You're a big natural.
Oh, oh, oh.
Yay.
You're a large natural.
I'm a natural.
You're a big natural.
Oh, wait.
Then I throw it.
Yeah.
It's basically like a granati.
Say hello to the lava.
The way you're facing is the way you're going back the line,
basically.
Think of like your...
It's like a basketball.
Oh, I'm out of ammo.
Let's see.
Come here.
I have ammo.
You do?
I'm my best.
Oh, there's ammo right here.
There's ammo right here.
I just had a connection error.
Oh, wait.
Oh, you can come back.
You can jump back on me from the game.
I can.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can jump back from Steam.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
I don't know what just happened.
Oh, I'm good.
I'm good.
Sorry, it was not me.
It was mint.
No, I know, but I can still give you a refill.
Oh, thank you.
That's so nice.
You can rejoin.
Wait, so I, how do I, um, I just from Steam?
You just right click on Muckus and then click on me again.
Okay, okay, okay.
Join the game.
All right, destroyer coordinates received.
I don't you think your turrets gonna Perchance kill me at
some point What how do you what How do you got like really
far we can hear you Oh that You think your turrets gonna
Perchance kill me at some point I don't know I guess we're
gonna have to wait and see No it's not going to Are the bugs
coming from the other side you guys By the way by any
chance?
There's no way I've checked this is the only way Yep I've
checked I'm coming in hot There's like no bugs spicy you
know what maybe come back in spicy hot i wonder if there's
like a server network convention you just destroyed henya's
gauntling gun oh my gauntling gun no i have the best aim
ever i have the best aim yeah you see this pad right here
man that was her gauntling gun right there guys i think the
mission glitch you know what i'm fine with this said the
mission glitches after somebody DCs so should we no we can
launch the rockets we'll just wait it out how do we wait it
out what's gonna happen well any more bugs I think the
rocket will explode right he'll just go right it says rocket
launch in progress but I don't think it's launching I don't
think it's progressing it doesn't automatically there's a
bug breach though the rockets shoot every two minutes Oh,
okay.
Okay.
What's six times two?
Yeah.
Will this kill me?
Yeah, they're right.
Listen, listen.
There's not one of them.
I can't even hide.
Look, look, they're gonna want you.
You want to see what it looks like?
I could, I could die in front of you.
Oh, I saw it.
I saw it from third person.
Oh, you did?
Good, good, good.
Do you hear that starting up sound?
Um, Kenya?
It's about to go up.
Oh, where are the enemies?
Nice, nice, nice.
You know what?
We don't need it.
We don't need enemies when it's all of us.
We can just do it.
We can be each other's enemies.
Yeah, there we go.
What the heck?
We can be each other's enemies.
That is so fucked up.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, I was resummoning them.
Oh no.
Yeah.
Me?
Only in the head.
Only in all the wrong ways.
I wouldn't...
Oh, but I think my suit are now cleaned.
True.
Moshi Moshi.
Oh, thank you.
Moshi.
That wasn't me!
That wasn't Hanya!
That was me!
No, I didn't do anything!
Hanya, you killed me!
Hanya, be careful!
What the fuck?
Guys, I think we need to restart.
I don't think the rocket's going up.
I don't think so.
I've only told you guys.
All right, let's get out of this.
I saw an Oshi.
What's going on in here?
It's an honor to kill my Oshi.
Uh-huh.
It's an honor.
Oh.
Uh-huh.
We're alive.
I think the mission was booked.
Man, you killed me.
Me, too.
Yeah, Mint, why did you kill her?
I kill everybody.
that's really fucked up I leave no prisoners shaking my head
mint shaking my head mint from independent it's because we
have a joke like it's usually it's shaking my head Zen from
Vshojo so here would be like shaking my head mint from
independent what I like to say is SMH mint for mint Fatomi
oh Fatomi fancy or may our estimation mint from made mint
channel made oh yeah mint from made don't know that's my
full name only my mom can say that made big channel you're
supposed to do your homework no i want to play pokemon more
you better do your head back no you can't make me yes bio
titans oh mint you're gonna love this one why oh it's my
cousin Uh-oh.
We're gonna fight my cousin.
You're okay with killing your family?
Oh, yeah.
Jump complete.
Oh, if it was good enough for the kings in Europe, it's good
enough for me.
That, oh, yeah, was like, he was so, so excited.
Oh, yeah.
This is really fucked up.
I say so, so myself.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
Why is it all farting in this planet?
It's all farting, though.
Thank you.
Uh oh.
It's because it's the planet.
Our planet's farting though.
Yeah, the planet is making a lot of gas, making shit hard
for us to see.
Oh.
The smell.
Oh, it's not giving me a drop point at all.
That was really weird.
Oh, is it because of the spore towers?
Oof.
No, not the spore towers.
The spore towers can only do so much.
but like it's not like letting me see anything can I get um
water no that's the that's the planet it's a gas planet so
that's the house supposed to be I'm gonna unready I'll be
right back no no no you can't okay you can't pause the game
mom just guard my body no no you go ahead go ahead we'll
wait we'll wait it's no stress I gotta go by some jab at the
cat go go go go go well did Hennium
Hey everybody, do you love your Oshii?
No.
Consider gifting five gifted subs right now to them.
Yeah, I agree.
Show your love while they're gone.
It's more fun to spoil them when they're not here.
That way you can't get yelled at for spoiling them.
Unless you like being yelled at for spoiling them, then
spoil them when they're back.
I hope you're having fun.
I mean, Mid likes being yelled at.
You know who clearly doesn't love being spoiled enough?
Haruka, because you never freaking stream.
I've literally streamed on Monday and then I had what about
before that I had remember I streamed for our new member I
don't remember ma'am I think I made a mistake I think he
should get the sub to Matara Khan for bringing us together
for this collab and it's she's a wonderful human human being
and I'm so happy I'm not a human I'm a bug and every Monday
this is for Min as well her podcast every Monday it's really
cool you all should watch her podcast it's so cool Mint and
Matara Sama special yeah I watched the first episode I gotta
watch the second and third and fourth by the way you're
behind I know I'm really behind I love you I'm kidding you
don't have to do it I like to watch my friends as shit I
love you you are still my friend even if you don't watch
every episode.
Okay, I actually have to mute now.
Damn you all!
Now I have to mute.
You've done it.
You're welcome.
Have fun muting.
Well, I have now successfully dominated all three channels
at once.
Mata may have me muted, but she didn't deafen me.
So everyone can hear me.
Well, yeah.
Hello, guys.
You guys having fun?
You having a good time?
mince chat hi mince chat i see you hello hello hello oh
she's back you know how to come yes you not streaming will
not stop me um yeah you not streaming cannot stop me welcome
back who the fuck are you i'm joking your chat went crazy
henya i'm sorry i don't know they always do this what the
heck why there's so many I don't know!
It's Haruka's fault!
She did that!
It's her fault!
Also, Haruka also has a hype frame.
Wait, what?
It's Haruka's fault.
What?
Wait a minute.
I got an egg sandwich!
Oh, describe taste.
A game?
What?
The fuck?
I'm typing my own offline chat.
Get out of here, guys!
Go out of the people I'm streaming!
Yeah, sorry.
Haruka said this thing.
Haruka said, spoil your Oshi by gifting five gifted.
So that's why you probably got a lot of them.
I'm going to let you know right now.
I don't say Oshi often.
That's what Tawakon.
Favorite streamer.
She doesn't say it often, but she did that one time.
Wow, you were really good.
Your impersonation is so bad.
It's true.
I hate it here.
Do you want to eat it a bit before we start?
I can let you.
I can let you finish.
I'm generous.
No, I'm good.
Oh, you sure?
I can't.
I'm good!
Might be the only time.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
Cool.
I care about my friend.
For every bug I kill, I'm gonna take a bite.
She's gonna snipe me the moment we land.
I mean, you hit this shit every bug and you didn't specify
what kind of bug, so you're kind of fucked.
Yeah.
I like the fucking mischievous Glint went to bed.
Is that that?
Yeah, you're done so You're you're done You're done You're
done But hello everyone, this is the Zen Treya planet and
welcome I'll be into your stage.
Oh, no, what a steak you do.
She's not even here That's why we can't even see the planet
Oh, no, Zen Oh, Zen from From the show Joe Zen from Zen Trey
Yeah, Zen Trey just so you're aware things are happening in
your stream even though you're not there they're still
happening i've literally told them to oh they're the
channels mint how do you feel about flying bugs oh i like
those ones do you like them if they're trying to kill you
maybe never experienced nice oh my god i did that i'm so
proud of myself what the what the what just what just got me
it a flying bug?
I don't see any bugs in the air.
Oh, you know what it could be?
Look at the floor.
Do you see those yellow things as you step on them?
Oh, what the hell is going on?
Sorry if I hit you.
Sorry, not sorry.
Oh my god, my AML.
Not sorry.
But this thing is a charger, right?
Charger, die.
Good job.
Good girl.
Do you see them flying in the air?
Oh, yeah, I do.
I see them now.
We have to kill the little mushroom that is not a bug that
is a dinosaur actually it's a oh what the what
i think um yeah yeah do you want to talk about it oh my gosh
i think i'm dead i think i'm dead you're you're alive you're
five uh it's a flesh moon i just start shooting then i start
I can re I can resurrect you baby.
I can still I need been resurrected.
Oh, I got you.
I'm not dead yet.
Oh, I'm not dead yet I met with the sharks, but we're still
not dead yet.
I'm dead Was it thank you mother you're welcome baby.
I got you baby the birds They they're gonna like lean down
when they lean down try to avoid them because that's when
they damage you Wait two of you died shit.
I just saw sorry I gotta if one of you comes back and you
have like a stratagem there's oh my god oh my god okay these
bugs are crazy I'm on fire if anybody has a stratagem please
God I gotta wait for a minute I gotta wait for there's three
chargers by the way there's a flying one too yeah yeah
there's everything um oh no that game glitch again said i
was killed by henna so that is a crazy glitch every single
time there's four charges every single time this game is
trying to set me up oh my god henna i think you're a
murderer i don't know Do you have murderistic tendencies?
Do you think that you want to murder?
I don't like here.
When you see a person, do you think I want to kill or?
Oh yeah, she does.
Have you not hear her go like, You might be a murderer.
She is.
No, she does.
In game, in game.
Where am I supposed to go?
I think I'm gonna get caught by a laser.
she's gonna get got sorry that's my laser that's my laser
piss whoa don't say that on my channel my viewers take that
personally oh when you say my laser i'm so fucking sorry my
laser oh are they is it like oh fuck man i'm sorry should i
oh i'm so sorry is that is that better yeah so much better
thank you you know thanks for understanding i just really
you know wait so i can't say the Another P word, E-N-I-S, as
well.
I don't know how they feel about that one, to be honest.
Peepie?
Peepie!
Wait, I'm uncomfortable.
We can say peepie, but we can't say penis?
Stop!
Peepie!
Whoa, whoa, how do you?
I'm gonna get complaints.
I'm gonna get complaints from people being like, you're
ruining mint.
You've ruined her.
It is your blood.
I can't believe Haruka would say that.
But they're gonna somehow blame me, Haruka.
Haruka, that's so fucked up that yo.
I'll get blamed for this somehow.
We'll get blamed together.
Be like, I can't believe Haruka for Bishojo cannot read the
room.
It's unbelievable.
I mean, Haruka and Bishojo.
I can't believe Haruka would do this to my Min from May
channel.
I can't believe Min from May channel.
I can't believe it.
sorry we can we can get blamed together i don't know why
we're blaming people what's going on i'm shooting bugs oh um
shoot them better shoot them better i'm doing it oh my god
we are the same her and i are the same i need a resupply
okay i got you already got you what are you so fast oh mint
from toothpaste coming down here mint from toothpaste i
stole that from chat i love i love reading chats, funny
words, and then stealing them.
I'm making two girls giggle.
Oh, shit.
Hey, yeah, they're biotines.
Oh.
Mint, I want you to see it.
What's that?
Let me try and summon him.
It's my distant cousin.
I want to see him.
Come here, biotines.
I saw your joke and they laughed.
How does it feel?
Biotines.
Mr. Biotines.
We're art, though.
Where are you?
I'm so excited to see him.
We're art, thou.
Bioliet.
Violet.
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
Oh, wow!
Do you see him?
Zoom into him.
Wait, how do I zoom in?
How do I zoom in?
Use the little scope on your gun.
Oh, yeah.
So what I'm in chat saying, don't look me shy.
Whoa, what do I aim for?
Oh, hello.
Oh, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Oh, I just like to tank it.
Oh, I don't...
I like to tank it, tank it.
I like to tank it.
Oh my God, there are so many biotitans.
I mean, not biotitans.
Chargers on this map.
I know.
There are so many of them.
Mags empty.
Oh my God.
Stinky, stinky, stinky.
Hey, don't call me that.
I told you that in confidence.
I'm sorry.
You can't help, you know.
You have no one.
You know, I want to speak to the truth.
Your stench is just really...
Your stench, I'm sorry.
I think you guys are smelly.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'm inside.
I'm inside the butt bug.
I know you said I'm insane in public, but I can't hold it
back anymore.
When did you last shower?
You came last night.
Okay.
What about you, mother?
Yeah, this morning.
Oh, I don't believe you.
I know, I'm sad.
I want it to be stinky.
I went for a quick run.
So you were stinky.
Yeah, and then I showered after my run.
Why can't I avoid you guys?
I like when there's a little stinky, you know?
Oh, I'm slowed.
Oh, no.
A little stinky is good.
Sometimes when you're slowed and you took damage, you can
stim yourself.
That way you'll, like, get a little boost of speed.
It saves you from the snare or whatever.
I'll submit next time I'm next to you, I can give you a
shield if you want.
But only if you want it.
I mean, I don't want your sticky shield or anything, you
know?
Mine.
You know what?
Fine.
You don't deserve my big shield.
What is up with you and referencing Yogi?
I actually, I want to rewatch.
I think I'm going to watch that for the Patreon.
You've been referencing it like crazy recently.
I'm only referencing that one sentence.
Because I need to rewatch it to reference the other ones.
Well, what were you about to think?
New Yokiyo.
It's like the Jaden Smith anime.
It's so good.
Oh, geez.
Oh, God.
I'm dead.
I'm down.
No, die.
Oh, yeah.
If you're a ghost and if you die in the game, are you extra
dead?
Oh, yeah.
She's never coming back to life.
No, no, no.
She won't even be able to be actually plasmed.
You die in the game, you die in real life.
real life oh that's so just like oh my
god we have a lot of chargers here this is this seems like
now you're in the thick of it yeah there's so many of them
you basically have to stick and oh my god oh i was in the
thing of it yeah you know what i'm referencing i'm so sorry
i got you i got oh god man oh i broke the rock wasn't that a
meme like long ago on the tick tocks it was a while ago yeah
guys i think we need to get out of here it's just it's all
chargers there's like three of them i think we just have to
run to the next vile titan i don't know if you come with me
what did i see you yeah just run just like keep running away
from here oh no and then if you're too far behind just yeah
yeah i'm i'm trying i'm doing that oh wait so actually you
know what no no no No, stay there.
I'll revive you.
Why did you kill me, Matara?
Why did you kill me?
Because, because, because I'll just revive you in the next
spot.
No.
Away from that.
Matara!
Matara reinforce with me now!
Reinforce me right now!
This is safer.
Use reinforce to call it dead teammates.
This is safer this way.
Trust me.
Source, trust me.
I'm carrying you in my pocket like a Pokemon.
I'm carrying you in my pocket like a little Pokemon.
Trust me.
I was caught illegally.
I was taken against my will.
No!
Oh, no.
I'm in the water.
She used a master ball.
I didn't even have a choice.
I am drowning under the water.
You can't die.
You have to res me.
Oh, she already resed you, didn't she?
No, I'm still not.
I was...
I was waiting for it to be safer.
Like, what is it gonna be?
I thought they resummoned you.
Be careful, they will be coming soon.
Nice!
Oh, there they are.
I killed something.
Wait, so...
Wait, why are you gonna use a control?
There we go!
Yeah, there's a lot of bugs here.
We need to... Oh, shit!
Oh, good one!
Wait, why can't you use a control?
Batara from Fy Shoujo, did you kill?
No, she launched the rocket onto herself.
Oh my.
Hey, did you see this shit?
What happened?
I didn't.
Run from the laser.
I don't know what the laser is, but I'm running.
You can see it.
If you look back, you'll see it.
You'll know.
Wait, can you guys use the command?
Or do I like reach the blind stuff?
Oh.
yeah we can use it i can't use it uh maybe it's on cooldown
no i can't i can't even see them like oh my god stem
why is there so many bugs on this map compared to the other
ones did i accidentally put us i don't think we had a hard
mode or what is going on we were on five for the last like
three missions
keep running just keep running okay i'm running i'm gonna
run towards everybody oh no he's catching up yeah run
towards them they'll be able to when he comes at you you can
like jump to the side when he's real close to you when
you're running try to look back a bit okay you cannot run
most bugs you can yeah except the little white ones if
they're in a group you usually should have to turn around to
kill the little white ones just run just run just run just
go yeah just run just run just run you're doing great oh boy
oh gosh oh boy just run to order towards them and they'll be
able to assist us.
I still jumped out of his way, but he...
I got you, Hanya.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm running.
Oh, he's right.
You're going to be able to assist us.
Friendship door here.
Oh, there's a guy in front.
There's a guy in front.
It's okay.
There's a guy behind, too.
Careful, Mim.
There's a guy behind you.
See, like, sometimes it's easy and then you get into a
difficulty and you're like, oh my God.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
That blew up, yes.
Now for the other ones.
These little white ones that you usually cannot run.
Oh, they're fast, yeah.
If they're in a group, yeah, they'll jump on you and stagger
you.
Oh, shoot.
But the rest of them, you can outrun them.
Oh my god, reloading is gonna kill me.
How you like the taste of freedom?
How you like that?
It tastes like mint, I think.
What, freedom tastes like mint?
Yeah.
And toothpaste.
To the best!
For prosperity!
Uh oh.
Prosperity awaits in the care of magnets.
What the?
Did you not read the company policy?
Thank you, Daya!
I didn't know!
Oh, I just threw something and I'm not sure what.
Don't worry, Hendy.
I got you back.
I think I know what you just threw.
I don't think that was me.
I don't think so.
Hold on.
Samples.
Democracy.
Oh, let's go.
Nice.
You have, um, oh, I'll just use this gun.
Let's go, why.
Keter, Keter, Keter.
Keter.
I'm gonna, should we go towards them?
Yeah, go towards them.
I'm just gonna kill this guy so he doesn't follow us.
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh, I got this suddenly.
I'm running.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I'll let you know when it beeps.
I'm running.
Running, running.
Oh, careful.
to your left are bugs.
Stop!
Is that good?
Yeah, if you heard the beep sound, it means that it's
aligned.
Maybe they're at your other left?
Yeah.
I'm killing some.
Go back, back, back, back, back, back, back.
Stop.
Okay.
Yeah, so getting a lot of chargers is hard when you don't
have like the items to kill them.
So, Henny, there's like a distinct beep sound coming from
the terminal that lets you know that, um, you aligned it
perfectly.
Oh, really?
Yeah, so that's why sometimes it's easy to do this on your
own if you can.
Here they come.
watching the war how about refill that's empty yeah all
right girls i will awaken the beast within the beast i will
awaken the beast within are you gonna wake the state or a
bomb oh my god i don't have a laser but i'm gonna do what i
can oh my god don't tell me that's gonna miss him okay it
still own world, you guys.
Oh, that's him again.
Oh, oh.
He's throwing up.
We're in the middle of two.
We're in the middle of two bug breaches.
Uh-oh.
Yeah.
So we got to go back towards them.
Or yeah, you're towards them.
Perfect.
I was in the middle of the bug breach.
Nick was doing great.
No!
I got you, Hena.
I got you.
No, I got her.
I got her.
Throw.
Oh god, I sorry, I put you in a pretty bad spot.
I'm okay.
Wait, that didn't kill?
I almost have him killed.
I just need to do one more Kusarkan and he's dead.
I need ammo!
There we go.
Good job!
Beautifully died.
I still can't.
I don't think I shot him even my Haruka from Bishojo.
That's my gamer girl.
That's my Canadian moose.
Ah!
that's my girl i got you nice oh never mind oh you like feel
back and pull back
um being no i can't still see the control god dang it you
still can't see the oh i've done that before wait oh really
yeah i don't know how i turned it back uh is anybody in your
chat i feel like they have to see it i know i've done that
before i know the bug you're talking about i think it's
usually when you have your map open when you have your map
open you like can't yeah press down to the trap again oh i
did but it doesn't work oh shit let me see what why did you
tell me you
Why do you need to know?
It's my skill.
So what are you trying to do?
How are you trying to open up your stratagem, Senya?
If I walked into it, it was going to kill me.
So what are you trying to do?
I'm looking at your stream now.
Are you trying to open your...
Oh, I'm trying to...
I'm pressing the control right now, but it doesn't see...
Like, usually they show me the like a stuff, right?
The arrow stuff.
But I can't see it.
Rare sample.
Oh.
No.
I'm gonna turn around.
Oh, that is weird.
I think I was okay.
No, we got him.
We got him.
Okay.
Maybe over there's a bait.
I can get him with this gun.
I think you'll be fine if we leave this mission maybe.
Yeah, yeah, I think that's it.
Yeah, he said!
This mission.
Oh, nice.
Good job.
I didn't do anything.
You're bait.
I know, I know.
But you still helped.
You were the bait.
We're gonna survive.
We had a very important job.
That's true.
I was delicious.
Minty freshness.
Over here.
You want a little bite of a...
Oh, geez, you mind?
Maybe that'll work.
Minty girl.
Hey there, big bug.
You want a little bite?
What's this?
Can I open it?
There's a chair.
Anyone want to sit?
You can try.
I got you.
It ain't working.
I'm trying.
She did it.
She fixed your problems.
I love her.
I probably should reload.
And...
What?
Are you going to kill us then?
I'm talking to the little guys.
Wait, I thought we were bumping over this democracy thing.
I'm killing the little guys.
if you're a little guy run run because you are in trouble
right now she will kill you oh yeah let my red thing go and
then oh sorry why did you not tell me that you were
launching some um missiles matara i died to be completely
honest with you it's my fault i just thought you saw the red
thing in front of you my bad you really overestimated how
good my vision you're right I too am blind and old well
you're not old but you're blind definitely the blind part
yeah all
right I'm coming in I'm coming in I
guess so it was so like matter-of-fact like yep that's
that's it that's it yeah I think we're gaming haruka we're
gaming we are we can't have you been to little we can't
we're gaming right now we were talking about that yeah i
have been i used to yeah yeah i um you used to what nothing
okay okay no run oh well i would so there i would go with
friends um but okay she's bragging yeah i have friends i
don't have any friends
Careful, Mink, there's Mink.
Look at you.
Mink, back out.
Mink, back up.
You were too!
You didn't want me fast at home!
You got a point, you got a point.
I'm slow.
I'm gonna go right on top of you.
She stopped stopping recently, okay?
She's trying to get her everything back.
Everything's getting back.
I miss out.
I can't even get my stuff back because you killed me.
Yeah, you can.
Where is it?
I'm stuck.
Let us kill the charger and then you're going to go get your
stuff, okay?
Okay, I'm going to give.
I'm going to get hit by the charger.
Oh, oh, wait.
I'm actually stuck.
Oh, no, no, no.
Wait, I'm actually stuck.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
It's a good thing you didn't get your stuff then, because
then you'll die again and you'll get your stuff after.
No, he's just staring at me.
I got him.
I got his butt.
Okay, let me...
I hope people are saying dive.
Oh!
Okay.
Get up now.
now run oh thanks guys run thanks i was safer i was safer
being there to be honest i think so too because i was
shooting his butt yeah you were i was distracting him yeah
we're pretty good i think they're fine yeah we're fine now
we're getting it still alive yep i'm still alive
uh i don't know how long i'll be alive for it to be honest I
gotta have to make sure my bitch Kenya stays alive.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yes, I'm your bitch.
Oh, sorry.
I gotta make sure my tongue Kenya stays alive.
This is the show, Jill.
You're getting acquainted.
I'm learning.
I'm learning a lot.
Oh, I'm out of ammo.
Uh oh.
Slay, da yo.
Do you have a second gun?
Press number two.
Yeah, but it's not good.
Okay, got it.
It's better than nothing.
Fuck my bitch!
Where the fuck are you?
All right, let's go towards them then.
Okay.
Actually, no, this is where we evacuate.
Oh, yeah, no.
Let's go towards them.
That's where we just run.
Why am I so slow?
They're too tall.
I think I'm going to die.
I think I'm going to...
Just run.
I'm...
I am.
I'm doing the best that I...
Oh.
I'm going to make that good.
I'm going to get closer than this.
Hey, hey, hey, get out of my back.
Oh, it's the little, a white one's done.
There are so many of us, oh my gosh.
I am.
Minx can come to us closer now.
I had no more stems, you guys.
I had no more stems.
Run, run to them.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna clear the little box here.
No, I'm, I'm dead.
Oh, oh, okay.
No, no, fuck up.
The ship is down all right.
We're waiting for everyone to come here.
Yeah, we're waiting for E, you guys.
Well, yeah, we're trying.
We were having fun doing bugs.
Why is it getting so low here?
Oh, this is water.
This is water.
No, go!
I think we're doing a really good job, right, Mata?
I think we are too, yeah.
We're gaming.
And then to the left?
Oh, to the left.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, my God.
Was that you?
No.
Guys, you should summon her next to you.
Summon her where you are.
And I'll run.
Cut my head off.
Cut my head into faces.
I can't read it.
Yeah, I think she meant the other left, you guys.
Here we go.
I'm coming.
Wait for me.
Why don't you guys just get in the car?
Get inside.
No, no, because then it'll leave.
No!
Oh!
Now you guys can leave.
It just...
I think it like lowers our experience.
Oh!
It lowers our experience, but it's not.
My samples!
Um...
Yeah, sorry, Haru.
Sometimes, like, I get...
I just start killing the bugs and not looking at the
mission.
I'm reloaded.
So you guys should have just been like, oh guys, we're at
the end.
We're doing the...
Because we were just having fun.
Do you see why I invited Haruka to this collab?
Because she actually gets the shit done.
Wait, it bugged?
Wait, some people say you died.
It didn't bug.
No, no, Kenya had the stratagem glitch so she couldn't put
down any stratagems.
Oh, yeah, wait, did she make sure that...
Oh, I made it!
Yippee!
Wait, why did I...
How are you the only one?
I don't know.
Huh?
I left them behind.
Did you actually run into the ship?
Maybe on accident, but I don't...
Oh no!
Minx.
Honestly, pretty bait!
Shake in my head!
Wait, this is my first time playing this game, okay?
Shake in my head.
Oh, the ship got damaged.
The shuttle extraction bug?
Oh, wait, if the ship get damaged, they will start the ship?
I think I was trying to get away from a bug and I dove into
the ship.
I'm like, pretty bait!
Dun dun dun!
Yippee!
I cannot believe it, Min.
You ruined everything.
I got to the ship!
I made it alive!
Out clean!
Oh boy!
I did it.
Everything I ever worked for.
How the fuck did Matara Khan do not die a single time?
That's crazy.
Yo, it's called gaming.
You didn't die a single time?
Bada bam, bada bing, bada boom.
Bada boom.
Bada bing, bada boom, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada.
Yes, Henya.
Learn these phrases.
You're not supposed to have capes.
Um, we are...
Hell divers?
It's a requirement to have a cape.
I'm sorry, yeah.
I just thought that we're superheroes.
We're not supposed to have a cape.
Listen, Finn, not wearing a cape is the most least
democratic thing we can do.
Oh, true, true, true.
It's...
True, true, true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are we not superheroes, you guys?
It's a superhero rule, but are we not superheroes we are
protecting we are bringing democracy is that not a superhero
thing that's pretty that's pretty my my headphones cut out
can you resay that whole thing i said Bada bing, bada bing,
bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing,
bing, bing, bing.
Bing, bing, bing, bing.
Here, I'll translate for you.
Bada, uh, mint see your thing.
I'll translate.
Bada, bam, bing, bing, bing, bing.
So she said that, are we not superheroes because we're
spreading democracy?
Because we have kids?
Are we not superheroes?
That's basically what she said.
Yeah.
Oh.
I think we're going crazy.
I think so too.
I don't know what's happening anymore.
Yeah.
I blame him, yeah.
I'm speaking my truth.
It's a truth, Queen.
Say it from your chest.
What is it wrong with your head?
Stay with your balls, man.
What am I saying?
Your truth.
Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing,
Bing,
Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing Bing, Bing, Bing,
Bing, Bing Bing, Bing, Bing Bing, Bing, you know what?
It's very rare when the second season OP pops in the first
season.
Guys, I'm gonna rejoin the game.
My game's still glitched.
Oh wait, why did I- Oh no, I spawned in the worst place.
Oh god.
But I missed you already.
It's not very often that the second season of an enemy's OP
is better than the first one, really.
What is that from?
I just know the song.
It's from Maschul.
Yeah, Machu-du, Machu-du.
It's really funny It's basically if one punch man goes to a
wizard school Oh, that's not a potter He basically So
basically he is born without any magic And he has to punch
his way And people are like Oh my god, that was his magical
power It's really fucking funny Just punching I like that,
that is pretty magic I don't want to spoil the first episode
Because it's really fucking funny So please watch Marshall
the it was fun yes i need to finish season two oh that is
not a person i don't like it i don't like it also mint this
is not your eyes this is just i feel like i'm playing metal
gear solid three right now oh no this is what it's gonna
look like yeah it's just it's because there's a fourth honor
oh i Not anymore.
Come back.
War never ends.
Summon me again.
Mataro Kahn.
Out of the atmosphere.
I gotta disappear.
Fuck.
I'm stuck.
There's a spore mushroom that I see.
Oh my god.
These guys in the sky?
Oh, what?
You're not dead yet?
It's a bird.
It's a plane.
It's a guy.
Oh, geez.
There's...
How...
How the hell...
There you go.
Oh, good job, Haru.
See, this is why I brought Haruka.
We needed a gamer.
Gamer!
I'm just a knight!
You are so annoying!
I just played game.
Oh my God.
No, please please.
Oh god.
Oh god, oh god!
Oh gosh.
Why there's so many of them?
Wrong way.
Oh, thank you.
go and fix the knife good job all right how do i carry
that's our girl where is everybody hiding from you i get
that hiding my way from you no don't turn your back now
oh my god let me take oh my god i cannot aim for these
birds.
I know they suck.
The one sucks.
He's nuts.
Yo!
Oh my gosh, little guy.
I will now graduate because this is the only peak humor I
can do.
My ear's bleeding.
From the Joker, the one.
It's a gift, Hanya, for me to you.
Thank you for the gift, Dave.
Shit!
You're welcome.
Oh my gosh.
Freedom never sleeps!
Sorry, I did not mean to say shit on your stream, but fuck,
I am about to die.
That's okay.
I say, I accidentally say bad things too sometimes.
Mint casually writes this in her nose.
Harka is about to breathe her last breath today.
Oh shit.
Oh, I see I said it too on accident.
Rights mean the death note.
Oh, I'm out of ammo on everything.
Those words?
It's okay, Mint.
I got you.
You do?
Where are you?
Well, I mean, I got the charger.
Oh, well, there was another charger.
Oh!
I got a gun!
What the fuck, do you?
I like how you said that.
That was actually kind of cute.
I got a gun!
I kinda like it.
Oh, yeah, I gotta get- No, it's not cute.
I was angry, do you?
I have this gun that, like, shoots lasers.
but if friendly people are in the line of fire it also
shoots the friendly people yeah yeah that's a funny thing
it's very fun that's why I use it that's fucked up Natara
not me hey I'm a tais the democracy like look wait is that
the art yeah the arc rifle I love it oh I'm reloading can
you reload when the bugs are right by you um i didn't
realize that it was going to be that kind of reload yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah the machine gun has that yeah yeah i
didn't realize all right let's go do the side mission mint
we're here let's do it okay science for science for science
i don't think i've done this one before i don't even know
what are we doing what's this i don't
I don't know.
I'm trying to find it.
I'm trying to look.
We should find, we should look for a computer.
A computer.
Okay.
But I don't see a computer.
I'm gonna go destroy X.
Good girl.
X.
Oh, it's the hell bomb.
Oh.
Hell bomb.
We don't have the hell bomb though.
Oh.
You have to call in a hell bomb near the gray building.
You sent us on a wild goose chase.
Hey, hey, hey.
We're already here.
Oh, I see it.
Okay, mint.
Yeah.
um run run far oh hey you're here with me daio yeah i'm here
daio i came here for you i got you getting killed on bakara
two times i'm here what did you do why did you do that to be
honest i didn't think you were gonna die by bad watch out
hey yeah you deserve that you deserve to mess it up where
are you i'm gonna land Did I miss out the hell bomb?
You messed up everything, Matara!
What's going on there?
Oh, I had to punch in the code in the hell bomb.
Fudge.
Okay, I'm sorry, Mint.
This is why I brought Haruka, because I don't know how to do
anything.
Yeah, I could tell.
Where's the bomb?
So, you have to go back inside and...
Yeah, I think I have to, like, activate the code on it.
Oh, Hanna, be careful.
I'm going to throw it.
Okay.
I'm running out of here.
I just have to find where I put it.
Where did I...
Guys, do you know where I summoned mom?
I'm gonna run the other way.
Woo!
Oh, I missed!
It's okay.
They broke it?
Okay.
Oh, thank you.
Did you do it?
I'm about to do it.
I think I'm gonna go to where Henya and Haruka.
Sounds good.
I think we should do that.
Nice, we did it.
There's a bug nest here if you want to do it.
Nice teamwork.
I don't want to do anything with you.
Oh my god!
The Russians are really broken and I'm not there to win his
game.
What the fuck?
Let's go.
Here, I'm going to refill my supply pack.
Nice.
Don't be anywhere near the bomb.
Oh, you put the bomb?
Yeah.
I put the bomb all right.
Oh.
Yippee!
Oh, my God.
There's a corner right there.
That is actually really fun.
Oh, here.
I'm here by the bug mask.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, wait.
I love you.
Not today.
I'm sorry, but you got to be careful.
What did I?
What did I miss?
What is it that I missed?
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize you were very close to me.
So I had summoned like my rock.
I was trying to kill the nest with my rock.
Let me give you a shield.
It's going to help.
No.
I'm sorry.
Where is the nest?
Oh, she didn't summon me.
We just...
I killed it.
Oh, okay.
What the fuck now?
Oh, shit.
You're fucked.
Let's go towards...
Big red laser equals splat.
Oh, fuck, oh, fuck.
Yeah, when the big red laser comes, it means like...
Oh, okay.
Okay, so the red beacon is...
Okay.
I got you.
The red is mad.
I got it.
Uh-oh.
Guys, I'll resummon you, but we're pretty far.
No, no, no, no, no.
I can summon my back.
It's okay.
Okay.
I got this.
I just got it.
Thank you.
I'm here now.
You got this hide.
I believe in you.
We're here.
Nice.
Close-ish.
Oh, we're kind of close.
We're pretty far, but it's fine.
No, I can see them fighting.
Thank you.
The girls are fighting.
The girls aren't fighting.
The bitches are shitting.
Oh, yeah.
Have you ever heard of that one?
Are you a girl that poops or a bitch that shit?
Are you a bitch that shit?
It's like, are you a girl failure or a girl boss kind of
vibe?
Oh.
I am a bitch that shit.
I think I'm a girl boss, but my chat thinks I think is a
girl failure.
You know what?
I'm inclined to agree to an extent.
I think you're a little girl failure.
What do you mean by that?
How do you mean by that?
Yeah, how do you come?
What do you mean by that?
These look kind of suggestive.
I think someone should hold your hand sometimes.
I think she wants to hold your hand, man.
I want to hold you.
Here's a refill.
I don't want to be an American.
Thank you.
And please.
Sample.
I need you to take care of the butt, man.
Oh, I'm here.
I'm going to go back and get more of the resupplies that...
What about if I died?
It's okay.
didn't die because i respect oh thank you you're coming back
okay i'm on his butt okay i'm ready to distract him oh my
god i'm stuck oh that's awkward oh that's awkward oh that's
weird oh that's great can we get fine to get themselves to
mint and macara and henya thank you stop shut up and harika
Oh, it's okay, Mitt.
I'm okay.
You got this?
Oh, you're okay.
You're fine.
Oh, there's some guys behind you.
It's just a flesh wound.
Yeah, I see.
Let me get the little guys behind.
You just keep running away, girl.
Oh, okay.
Oh, there's a bug breed.
You can actually just run to them.
Okay, Mitt.
Yeah.
Just run.
Let's run to them.
Run to them.
Oh, look at him.
He's, like, missing a leg.
Oh, my God.
Please, please.
Idiot.
Dummy.
Stupid guy.
Stupid, stinky.
whoa man you can't say that did i go did i go too far did i
go too far again i think you're doing fine go towards them
okay okay i'm really sorry i didn't mean to i didn't mean to
i take it back i regret my words and actions what did she
say i said is mint being problematic as usual
guys i thought i knew you better yes i'm here yes i'm here
by the way way we haven't done the main mission yet we've
just been running around being little silly goofy girl i've
been doing the main mission yeah have you done any of the
main mission i don't think so i've done a try look at that
we're getting together yeah okay well i also was here i came
in like a little later you were here for the emotional
support yeah i was really here the whole time by the I was.
I showed up.
I killed an egg.
I helped.
Stealing our fucking integrity and our work and our body's
putting tears.
We died three times.
Oh, shit, shit, shit.
You see that eagle?
Run, run, run.
I think you should go towards it.
Oh.
Hennon, you try.
Oh, happy birthday.
Happy birthday.
Oh, it was Hennia.
You're you're oh, she eagled you.
I didn't get eagled.
I mean, she tried to kill you.
Ah, that's okay.
yeah see I told you we're on difficulty five I think you
underestimate my degeneracy oh I definitely don't I'm gonna
get the bug nest actually uh Haru I might need assistance
because I only have only have a few grenades this is a
really big one I have one no no no no I'm getting my
supplies real quick hey hey You already summoned the
resupply?
Are you okay?
I did.
Can somebody punch me?
Oh.
Um, I don't know what I'm gonna do.
What the heck?
This is a big bug nest, like it's good experience.
I didn't know!
Wait, you're inside the rock?
What the fuck?
Oh yeah, it's a bug.
Um, um, I'll blow up the rock!
Do it, do it, do it!
Okay, okay.
Um, wait.
How do I...
Okay, hold on.
Uh, I gotta make sure I don't die.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't die.
You're in the rock.
Yeah, there's no way we can get you out of there, Henya.
Blow up the rock!
Well, at least that's one way to save her.
What the fuck?
My body!
Come, come, come, come, come, come, come.
There's a big bug nest, but I don't have any grenades.
Thank you, man.
Thank you.
Okay.
I have grenades.
There's a huge bug nest.
Like, eight holes left.
Yeah, but this is two, and there's like eight holes left, I
think.
Well, you know what?
I'm good at filling holes.
I need your help.
Wee!
Where is it?
You'll see, you'll see.
We're going to...
Where the bugs are coming from is where it is.
Oh, oh my goodness.
Ah!
Oh!
Oh my god, you speak Momo?
Do you speak Momo?
Does that how Momo speak?
That's Momo's speech.
You speak Momo.
Fire in the hole!
You don't want IT!
My queen!
Oh my goodness.
uh-oh it's all min's fault this is your fault it's my fault
yeah it's all your fault you bitch that she's happy to be
the little villain oh oh i'm really man min speaks your
language that is so cute
is that it oh i see it the steam's coming up yep that's the
hole you need to get up if i throw it from here you think
it'll reach try what's the worst that can happen but you
miss what you kill i think i missed uh hold on oh mint oh
you got this man i believe i got it good job girl good job
girlies we have 23 minutes left let's uh let's oh we got
this one here too as as my grandparent used to say uh how do
i tag the map again can you remind me haruka Hold tab and
then you hold right click and then you can just.
Oh, hold right click.
There we go.
You hold right click to move like your mouse and like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna get some more ammo.
Oh, yeah?
Okay.
I'm coming.
Yeah.
Haru?
See, senorita?
Can we get the ammo?
Oh, I already recalled it.
You already used all of it?
Me?
Oh.
Or you mean it didn't come down yet?
No, I haven't come.
I just called it.
Okay.
it then we get one more it's a little hack it's a little
game oh my gosh why am i always climbing oh my god could you
guys already leave it out already yeah i dropped they're
down here they're down here are you far is there a ping is
there how do you ping in this game q hi q q oh my god you
need to stop it right now.
Let's run to the other egg.
I have the Riz.
After all these times.
Riz.
Do you have any Riz mint?
Some would say yeah.
I like how Mata literally called you out by laughing like
that.
Who would say yes?
My mom?
What are you talking about?
Like, she's... Why are you flirting with your mom?
Okay.
Oedipus.
Oedipus fauntal.
Oedipus?
What is that?
I don't know how to Why do you think making fun of somebody
whose native language is in English is funny?
It's not even English!
Min, you're getting cancelled.
I'm writing my tweet right now, Moustique.
Uh, one second.
You're getting cancelled.
I'm writing my cancellation.
Right now.
I'm gonna...
It's Greek.
I know, but...
Hold on.
Wait a minute, I have to do this to me.
Mint, mint, mint.
Yeah.
Come over here and look at this and tell me what it looks
like.
Where are you?
Wait.
It looks like a little onion.
This?
The onions?
It looks like a bunch of onions.
Onions.
A bunch of big onions.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he missed me.
You know what, mint?
This is me writing out my twillonger right now.
I can't even...
What are you doing?
Where are you?
Mint from the main big channel in...
I can't believe it would be fun of I can't even hear you
over the bugs
Oh, thank you We should run though There's a few chargers
And charge these nuts You said it, you said it, you said it.
Your goddess.
I am.
Where did I die?
Over there.
You see me?
You died like right or over here.
You can see it on your map.
No, I know.
I just always say it out loud over here.
Oh, smart.
You know in puzzle games when you're like, what would I do
if I was this?
And then somebody gives you the solution.
You're like, no, no, I'm just thinking out loud.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, that's my body.
No, I totally.
I'm like, hey, chat, here's the signal for you to, ask
questions i'm like hey chat blah blah blah yeah it doesn't
work though it doesn't work they never read you can have
like no spoilers read what i'm speaking out of my mouth they
they won't listen they can't read my lips read my lips words
are hard listening is harder i don't know i think the are
pretty good oh yeah we'll see about that play a puzzle game
i dare you i have played we played you know what you should
do i've been playing like i play a game with my friend
called escape room similar oh yeah i heard about that before
i heard about that yeah that's a great puzzler if you want
to put your brain to the oh that's a puzzle game yeah
because it's like you're trying to escape from the room
there's a bunch of puzzles for you to solve and i don't I
played one of those it was so funny.
Oh, really?
Like those like, whatever, like, we were here together type
of vibes.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my God, the bugs are here.
Oh, we are here.
I love that game.
Oh, oh.
The bugs are here.
Oh, oh, hello.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Hi.
Why?
I don't know why these bugs remind me of my cat.
I don't know.
The way they crawl at me reminds me of my cat, I think.
Are you saying your cat's a fucking demon from the hell?
Maybe.
Well, like cat like owner, you know?
Are you a demon?
That means I raised him well.
You know, they have those pictures of dogs that start
looking like their owners.
Oh, yeah.
If Mint's cat is misbehaving, you know why?
Hey, everyone.
I'm going to open the expression point.
I'm coming.
Ouch.
Yeah, let's run to the extraction.
Mint, run towards me.
Run towards me.
I can help.
Where is it?
I need it's behind you.
Oh my goodness.
It's at the opposite side.
Oh, you can resummon your stuff at the extraction point.
Oh, he killed himself.
That's fine.
Oh, okay, okay.
You can?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because they have a cooldown, right?
Thank you.
If you look right now, your sub's gonna have a cooldown.
Oh, yeah.
I can call them.
Yeah, yeah.
You can call them again.
Usually what we do, as soon as you get to the...
Oh my god, not Heavenly playing Driscoll Rain 2.
Of course he is.
Go to the blue and go to the blue.
My drone!
We're going to the blue.
YAMI-YAMI.
YAMI, yAMI, yAMI, yAMI, yAMI.
YAMI, yAMI.
YAMI.
One minute, one minute.
One minute.
Doing good.
Yeah, it just kind of looks like my cat.
And he does that.
I cannot wait to be the judge of that.
That's your cat.
Like, that's your cat.
Attack you like that.
No.
I'm sure.
Why not?
Forkway, no.
I mean, sometimes.
I like how you've been saying forkway because of me.
Forkway?
I feel like I stole that one from you.
Yeah.
Forkway.
Jitas de Polo was mine.
I've had that one.
That's been mine since forever.
Oh, uh-oh.
Perkoua?
Uh-oh.
Oh, play no.
But Jitas de Polo is mine and only mine.
I'm the only person.
Oh, nice kill.
Ah!
Um.
Hey, oh, sorry, man.
I should have warned you that was playing Eagle.
That's okay.
I'm used to it by now because of my...
Oh, because of what?
No, it won't.
Yep.
Um, yeah, you earned me.
Because I'm a Tauracon!
Yeah, you earned me.
Uh-oh, two Toshes.
You earned me!
Yeah, you earned me!
I'm landing!
The planet's here!
How to catch it!
Can everybody get to the shuttle, which is fine?
I'm on my way!
Ow!
Oh, uh...
And some say she's still on her way.
Ah!
How is this gonna go in?
Anyone want to raise me?
Uh, where was it?
No!
I got your samples, which is more important than your life,
but that's alright!
Oh, actually, I was concerned about the samples, so, you
know.
Yeah.
I got the samples.
Samples, everything.
It's okay because I left you guys last time, so, um...
Yeah, you kind of dished us.
Now it's, uh...
Now it's...
Real died.
it's even yep and we're all best buddies for it you know you
i i got you guys you guys got no no no yeah who are you yeah
i don't know i don't know my gosh i love you guys oh my god
oh my god i'm sorry min we have to kick you out uh i think
mouse is coming online so we want to make it yeah i'm sorry
yes sorry yeah i'm not do you know this mint person who is
she No, no.
She's been, like, following me around ever since I summoned
her.
No, I mean, like...
I mean, like...
I mean...
Yeah.
This is so great.
We're just one big happy family, you know?
This is great, old friend.
Look, I'm also in this picture.
There's also me, too.
Your hands popping out.
That's crazy.
Haru, did you teach her how to...
buy guns and stuff yeah should we teach her so she tries
different guns no i can't afford them what about stratagems
if you come where i am no i know i um i bought the the eagle
okay you can buy more stuff i don't have enough money oh
wait yes i do now you have enough money for chicken holy
shit i kind of want chicken nuggets oh is this what's it is
the stalwart good every gun i only have 9 000.
oh yeah you'll get more as we keep playing okay okay my wife
asked me to stop singing wonderful wonder wall to her
stalwart i said maybe okay i like that arc time oh henya's
about to be out for murder yeah i'm going for arc day oh
this is a 12 minute mission So this one, we got to go fast.
You don't think she knows about the R menu?
No.
Mint's chat, has she been using R to buy guns?
What do you mean R to buy guns?
If you go into R, oh yeah, what do we mean?
And then you go into Warbon.
You see R, press R.
R.
Do you see it says Hell Divers Mobilize?
Do you see that?
Yeah.
Okay, and now you can buy the guns in there.
Yeah, don't forget that.
going down the gun that I'm using it's on page five out of
eight it's called the site what did I get I really like it
uh I get like get the guns I usually try to get the guns the
grenade and the super credit oh wait did I I think I bought
something on accident when I meant to wait that's fine I
thought so it's a battle pass so the more so basically you
have to lock some of the pages be able to move down a page
basically so you didn't technically fuck off you have to
unlock oh i see okay i thought i was redeeming oh my god
this is what's this thing a super credit was i can't see oh
so super credits is like the current like in blocking
currency but you could find that shit in the overworld and
but get them from the battle pass too i want to be able to
climb it's super it's super free to play friendly nice yeah
yeah yeah you just have to play a lot you know yeah it's not
like i have 141 hours of this game what's the what's the
grenade that launches immediately oh that's called the high
impact rate and that's in several pages down okay oh i think
i got that i believe in
oh wait the game is always free to play you can even collect
super credits in game like if you play a lot of hours you
don't have to spend money i mean you but you spend money to
buy the game for sure but oh yeah buying like At some point,
right?
Yeah.
Come on.
Gotta spend money.
How do I...
What?
Oh, that's what you meant.
You have to buy the game.
Okay, okay.
Sometimes I've seen people come and chat be like, Oh, is the
game free on random games?
I'm like, why?
Why do you...
Why do you think it would be free?
It could be.
I don't know.
It could be, but why?
Wait, how do I change my...
How do I change my weapon and stuff?
Oh, we have to...
She has to...
Great.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Come to come here.
Actually, you can change it during the mission, but if you
come to this computer right here, and then you go into his
armory, and then character booster, you can, like, see
everything.
So you can go into armory and then change your armors,
change your stuff.
Let's try this one.
Is it equipped?
You know what else you can change?
Everything.
These nuts.
He's gone.
We lost her.
The Jeevra.
Wait, but this one...
We lost her.
Oh, I guess this one has a longer fuse time.
But this one...
Okay.
I kind of look like a bug.
I'm so high.
Shit.
Oh my god, my face.
Oh yeah, Haru, what time did you go to sleep today?
I don't think you really want to know.
Yeah, I do.
Is it 4 p.m.?
Wait, where's the other gun that I got?
No.
It was 1 p.m.
Do I have to...
order that one some of the other guns you have to order like
you know in game when you can put a gun yeah yeah like you
summon from the big crate some of the guns you summon from
the big crates shotgun so there's your primary weapon which
is like your regular gun secondary weapon which is like a
little revolver grenades and then you summon special guns
yeah yeah yeah i figured the special gun i figured yeah yeah
so the special guns like it just depends what you like to do
okay for me i hate ammo so i always try to get guns that
don't use ammo
Oh, wait, here we go.
I ate it.
That's the most evil laugh I've ever heard from you, and I'm
terrified for my life.
No, I've heard more evil.
But I go to bed tonight, and if I have a sleep paralysis,
and I hear that evil laughter, I know it's too.
I'm the sleep paralysis demon coming to visit you.
Wait, so are you a demon now?
Are you a ghost?
My sleep paralysis ghost can't be back to you.
I'm a ghost, I'm a ghost.
What is it?
Yeah, I was very confused.
I swore so...
Mbata, your ritual was disturbing.
I don't know what I messed up in it, genuinely.
I'm a ghost.
Okay, this mission is fast.
Fast.
We go in, we kill, we get out.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
Boom.
I already forgot what I already put.
I already put the microwave on fire.
What are we doing?
We all scratched at once.
Instruction's unclear.
I already blew up the house.
One of these two.
I don't know why that reminded me of that.
I still have this game audio turned off.
Mint, you're getting it.
the vibe i think i don't know it's still fun though here we
go i feel like singing the song right oh yeah wait okay you
get it you get it that's our girl so run towards the red
stuff because that's where the holes are close as many holes
as you can okay you know what else we can close the hole
with god gone what you thought i was gonna say no i i was
not i can't believe you thought what i don't even see red on
the map yeah because it's like sort of so this planet so the
shitty thing about this gas planet is that it covers up the
compass so we don't get to see anything just run until you
find by ourselves he's asleep don't let him wake up don't
let him wake up
Yeah, take that.
With the green bugs, what's their place to shoot them in?
The phase as well.
Because they're armored nursing stores, since.
Oh, they explode.
They're more annoying.
Yeah.
You gotta hit them in the phase.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Are you kidding me?
No.
I'm kidding.
No, I'm not joking around me.
It is indeed a thing.
I can't tell if I'm heading somewhere.
Maybe I was.
This is the thing that exploded last time, right?
Oh, bobo, bobo, bobo.
Easy.
Breezy, beautiful.
Oh, God.
Cover girl.
Give me the stupid sample.
Oh my God, this is the stupidest sample ever.
What's the sample?
I like using the high impact grenade on them, this pure
muzzle.
They died a one hit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's March.
Like on their face?
already.
Yeah, this is a fast mission.
You just gotta run.
I haven't found it yet.
I haven't found any.
Oh, I found I found one.
So oh, there's one.
There's one there.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
I found some hooves.
I'm putting down an eagle.
Did not come in here.
Oh, wait.
Putting out what?
Okay, okay.
I'm not coming.
Oh, I'm in somewhere.
Oh, okay.
I missed it.
Oh, there's a stalker.
He's invisible.
That's a stalker.
I got it.
Those are annoying.
Oh, no.
I thought the stalkers come on harder difficulties.
Oh, is this an invisible one?
Yeah.
We just need three holes and we're done.
Wait, is this one over here?
Yeah, you see the stalkers coming out of here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see, I see, I see.
Wow, you're right.
One impact grenade really does kill them.
That's crazy.
Oh my God.
Oh my god.
You're doing amazing, Mint.
I'm so sorry, Mint.
She's not sorry.
She's doing it on purpose.
It's because you haunt her at night.
It is because I... Oh my god.
Wait, where is it?
Where is it the hole?
Oh my god.
What the hell is there?
Oh, I'm right next to it!
I'm right next to it!
There's no grenade in there!
I'm trying!
Got it!
Alright.
If you ever see a stalker, Mint, you kill those fuckers
right away.
okay yeah it's like a big white guy he's really really scary
those are the guys you cannot outrun they will chase you to
the ends of the fucking map oh no god they're like obsessed
with that oh oh oh oh uh hold on yep there we go get me in i
love impact grenades that's why i never want to switch them
oh man i'm so far from my job we're just looking for three
more holes three more holes yeah i clogged the first five
wait no we need only one more oh yeah so we only oh my bad
is that me found something how do you know what the combat
oh if you look at the map it's basically when you like get
out of the map oh oh is when you leave the combat zone Is
this?
Is this a sample?
Arthios, you just have to type exclamation mark mint, not
mint.
Just exclamation mark mint.
Me, that's me.
Is this- Yeah, that's her.
Oh, that's not a bug hole.
That's uh-oh.
I'm mint.
You got him, right, Hadoot?
Yeah, you got him.
That's not me, that's H spherical.
You got him Hena.
I'm age 2.
She's age 4.
Yeah, I'm age 4, not age 2.
Nothing to worry about.
No, I'm age 2.
She's age 4.
Why are you guys?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm H2 and she's H4, right?
Wait, oh, is that why we're M1 and M2?
Yeah, I'm H4 and you're H2.
M1 reporting for duty.
Oh, I got a rare sample.
I mean, there's M1 and M3.
Yeah.
Oh, I see the other holes.
I see them.
I'm following you then.
Yeah, follow me.
M1 to M3.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, I see it.
I'm going towards it.
I'm going to it.
Not.
Don't go too close to it.
I sent a bomb.
Well, you could have said that like first night.
I said it.
No, you just said don't go close.
Well, I mean, what do you think I would do when I first find
the hole?
I would block it.
Oh, oh, oh.
I don't know.
Please, let me out.
Let me out.
It's like the opposite of let me in.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
Oh, no, you won't.
You're gonna live.
Oh my god.
You said I would live, you liar.
I lied.
Fuck, I accidentally got- I accidentally took your gun and
I- Ugh.
My gun?
Can you revive them, Henya?
Okay, okay, okay, hold on.
Yeah, I accidentally picked up a different gun and then I
couldn't switch.
Help me.
Oh, yeah.
Hania, no pressure.
Well, I already coded.
Good girl.
Yeah, good job, H2.
Oh, thank you.
I meant no pressure, like, hurry up.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's a lot of bugs.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, God.
Oh, I'm going to die again.
No, you're fine, man.
Don't worry.
I was killed by nothing.
I just died.
That's what they all say.
It just said killed by blank.
Oh, maybe that's a weird bug.
Killed by blank.
I don't think I've seen that before.
I've seen it a few times.
How did I miss?
Oh my god, how could you miss that?
How could you miss that?
It was right in front of you.
How did you miss?
When everybody's looking, I feel weird.
I felt that.
You know what, Matta?
I'm getting deja vu.
You said this shit to me a month ago.
Which one?
That performance anxiety.
So I told you everyone's watching you do the arrow games.
They're like, no, stop.
I have a performance anxiety.
I do.
It's true.
I, you know, please turn the lights off.
Right?
I'm dead, by the way.
So, uh...
I thought you're already dead because you're a ghost and
everything.
Ah.
I'm so fine.
By the way, you should try not dying in this game so that
you can do damage.
Yeah, that's a good plan.
I'll try that.
I don't think it's subtle.
I don't think it's a subtle bit.
I don't think that was very subtle.
Four minutes.
Where is the extraction?
Oh, I see the extraction.
Okay, let's run to the extraction.
Just see the...
I say let's run.
Meanwhile, you guys are already there.
She told me to run, but I was already there.
I'm on my way.
Yeah?
You're closer to me.
Pressure board.
call friendship door where are you baby can't see if someone
get my rare sample that i draw i got them don't worry i
picked them up okay thank you i got you bitch thank you you
you wanna do friendship with Haruka i've done it before yeah
I meant that I already done it friendship ended with Haruka
I think I was waiting everything ended with Haruka no I've
got it The friendship has been rekindled.
The friendship has been rekindled.
Okay, hit it.
They really did it.
Yeah!
And now I'll proceed to push you.
Oh, thanks.
He's in the room.
What is that?
We've got two very samples and some superpowers.
Guys, I don't know how to tell you this, but we should
probably help Hania.
Probably.
Yeah, could you?
Oops.
No.
I think Hania's got this.
Yeah.
Guys!
I think you're a pro.
Oh, I got you, Henia, Henia.
What's the big explosion?
Oh, my God.
Run.
I got you, Henia.
I got you, baby girl.
I'm running.
No, no.
I came to your rescue.
M has come to.
Got a rescue.
Oh, I tried to dodge, but I just did a silly.
Yeah you only had a don.
I don't.
And I'll be really proud.
I'm offense.
I'm not defense.
You know what they say?
Best defense.
Right here.
Yeah!
Oh, what the?
Where did he come from?
Where did he go?
Oh, Hanya killed me.
He was married a long time ago.
Oh, it must be game glitch.
Must be game glitch.
Oh, game glitch, game glitch.
Must be must be.
10 seconds, 10 seconds.
I love it.
Let me in.
Don't leave without me.
I have visual on the extraction zone.
Let me in.
Preparing for touchdown.
Arriving at LZ.
So, Mint, every time I play with Zen, when we're all running
into the ship, She just punches me as I'm about to run into
the ship every time.
Yep, she does that.
Every single time.
That's her zen.
She what?
Oh, really?
It's fine.
I just heard it.
Ah!
Were you going to push somebody off the ship?
Don't tell.
Huh?
When you were telling that story?
Yes.
What about my story?
I what?
I was like, you pissed?
What did I want?
Why?
You were going to push somebody off the ship, weren't you?
tell that story.
That's what you're saying.
I deserved it.
What happened, Matara?
No, no, I deserved it because I died.
What happened?
You deserved it because you died?
You only deserved it because you were about to do something.
Troll me, weren't you, Matara Khan?
Troll me?
If I wanted to troll, I wouldn't explain.
Troll Khan?
Troll Khan.
Troll Tara Khan.
Or, as Hania would say, Khan Tara, Khan,
My channel.
All my streams get demonetized anyway.
All of them?
On YouTube?
For real?
A good bit have been recently, yeah.
What have you been saying?
What kind of shenanigans?
No, it's like a music stuff that happens.
Oh, it happens.
So stupid.
Have you considered not like playing copyrighted music?
No, it's because like channels will like upload music from
games and then even though they're not the actual owner of
the music and then they'll claim my videos.
Oh yeah, that happened.
Yeah, I had that happen too.
One time I put like Bach.
I actually looked up classical like no copyright music and I
got like 15 or something claims for that.
And I said no more.
You guys are getting BGM and nothing else.
Yeah, it's so awful.
Yup, yup, yup.
It happens.
That's why I like to use video game music a lot.
You have to be careful because sometimes like what she just
said that channels will.
Yeah.
Well, maybe because I stream on Twitch and I know that I
play a lot of playing games with the BGM music seems fine.
But that's that was my point saying if it's okay to play the
game with the BGM then it should be okay.
But that is really dumb.
Yeah, it's silly.
yeah it happened it happened it's how um how do y'all feel
about that being the last game feel feel good you don't want
that last one yeah you want more i'm on because i've been
streaming for eight and a half hours and i have a big day
tomorrow yeah no worries i have to eat my lunch so i think
that's a good time yeah good lg lunch time what are you
gonna eat panya yeah what are you getting sandwich today i
don't know maybe i want to get it i guess okay okay yeah and
you're Was it?
You're not going to share this with the class, can you?
After all the shit we've been through together, after all
the deaths that we've died, and all the people, all the
books that we killed and stuff, you're not going to share
it.
Okay.
I understand.
Have a nice day.
This is me posing with my ocean.
Well, let me just run through and ruin it.
Hey, stop ruining my picture!
Get out of my picture!
My photo is not even...
I'm in the middle, I'm in the middle of me, me, me, no!
Me, me, no!
Me, me, me!
She saw me, she listened to me!
Yay!
She loved me.
You'll never have another You'll never have another hug
again.
And you can have one?
Gonna dance again.
Yay!
I'm too slow.
That was so much fun though.
Yeah, it was so nice to catch up again, baby.
Yeah, thank you for today.
Yeah!
I had a lot of fun.
I hope you learned a lot, Mint.
If you ever want to play again, let us know.
Now at least know how to play the game.
yeah this game is really fun i like it a lot oh my god so
nice to catch up with you mint yeah let's play again soon
yeah i'm so down i want to play and then again oh i forgot
the name the zombie shooting one that we were talking about
it leford dead too yeah i want to show that one too i show
down for leford dead that was really fun that'll be fun
that'll be fun we get all the I'm always around, but if you
also want to invite other people, I'm cool.
I got a busy time.
So keep me in mind or don't.
Yeah, whatever.
I always keep you in mind.
I never think about you.
Okay, but we're recording tomorrow, I think.
In case you forgot about me.
We have to keep up the act.
Oh, yeah, yeah, you're right.
You're right.
I hate you.
Yeah, I hate you.
Bye, guys.
Thanks for gaming.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye!
Well...
Oh, what?
Who's still here?
Oh, it's just me.
I usually like to be... Yeah, I usually like to be in the
person that opens the door for everyone to leave first and
then you left.
I just... I just, uh...
Didn't open Discord quickly enough.
No.
it was so nice to see you again yeah let's play again soon
hell yeah yeah i'll leave the door first you can hold the
door this time okay i'm holding it for you madame oh thank
you i love you love you bye bye bye by the way you smell oh
she ain't wrong i don't know maybe oh my gosh my
I'm so tired.
Hello, madam, mid-Mint Phantom.
If you see this message, that means that the gifted train
has subsided.
I hope you're having fun gaming.
Oh, my gosh.
I just realized, was there like notifications popping up the
whole time?
Big boss has become a membo.
Oh, you forgot to kill robots.
Oh, we didn't get to kill the robot.
I actually have no idea how many members.
Holy moly.
Why are there so many?
What the?
Like 20.
Why did there be so...
Why did this...
membership bomb um sorry if i was so bad at the game but um
you know first time playing but it was a lot of fun matara
was so helpful trying to like i mean sometimes but there's
like so much of the game that even i think if you like
explain as much as you can you are gonna forget something
you know what i mean like you're gonna you're gonna be like
oh i should have i should have talked about this or i should
have mentioned this who's this still remember filling out my
very first what a rush what a rush indeed me I'm the
shipmaster of this super destroyer I make sure you have
everything you need to spread managed democracy to our
enemies yes thank you managed democracy wait to our enemies
wait a second what do you mean by that welcome to the bridge
hell-diver thank you oh la la la la
this game is pretty though it's actually very pretty when i
say that i hope you're doing well i've not been able to
super chat in a bit when i give you some money now that's a
okay if you have not been able to super chat please don't
ever feel bad okay please please please what a cool way to
watch you play doom today oh my gosh like you know what i
can see doom guy in this a little bit oh my gosh look how
cool wait uh i'm trying to get a good angle like on the
other here we go wait stop stop like look how pretty hold on
i'm gonna get rid of all of us even me it's so pretty i feel
like a doom collab with this game though would be perfect
like you have oh my gosh can you imagine running from the
coco demon and like um having like the guys and stuff.
That'd be awesome.
Actually, I feel like, oh my God.
That would be so awesome.
This is a very doom eternal screenshot.
Hold on.
Actually, I can be next to him.
What am I doing?
Stopping myself from oh, oh.
Oh.
Uh, I have to do this.
I don't know how tall.
He said seven foot, so...
How tall would I be next to someone who's seven foot?
Lower?
Like here?
No.
I think like here.
Did you like the game?
Yes!
I had so much fun!
It's a lot.
It's definitely like...
sword um it's not a game that i think i could play for like
i mean i played for four hours almost today but it's not a
game i think i could do for so much just because it's like
everything overload like it's like there's this guy coming
over here you know it's just a little bit of a sensory
overload in a bit of a way but um you would be at his waist
no i would not No, I would not.
You guys, I'm not that small.
Yeah, it's a tense game for sure.
But it's so fun.
It's nice with friends.
Yeah, I can see.
I think by myself, I would be like...
You know, I would get a little...
I mean, I already got overwhelmed.
But it's still a lot of fun.
Around the tummy and chest.
Wait, so...
Like this.
this is me don't talk to me or my son ever again oh hell no
let me also bring up my other arm I only have one arm up
there we go
is it great today just do image training of venom snake
diving away from enemy yeah that's the one thing it was the
diving it's because it's alt I might rebind it to be honest
to be like space or something because you don't use space
for anything right not that I know of know of but it being
alt just like messes up my fingers
I put it on shift oh well you use it for climbing unless
you're running that's true yes yes that's true that's true
yeah vaulting is space then I'll I'll figure it out I'll
rebind it to something that isn't so uh I use extra mouse
buttons.
Oh, that's a good idea, too.
Like the side ones.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So.
Mouse wheel for climbing?
What?
Really?
That seems...
Is that normal?
Hmm.
Seems...
I don't know if I like that.
Ah.
I don't know.
do dive more than vaulting.
That's true.
I need something that I can like click really quickly, you
know, to get up and dive and get up and dive and get up and
dive.
This game has stealth.
What, when you crawl?
That would make sense, because there is crawling and stuff.
But yeah, hopefully you guys have fun watching our chaos.
We had a bit of friendly banter.
we're you know like i said just a big happy family blowing
each other up you know when she calls me a bitch it's like
you know it's i know it's out of love when i shoot her in
the head it's out of love takiz oh thank you for the five
gift and thank you a lot of screaming yeah oh my gosh it's
almost midnight for me
you're pretty good yeah that was fun though was lots of fun
so um would like to oh i'm lagging would like to play again
sometime but tomorrow tomorrow is sexy time oh my gosh i
can't wait to play the bunny girls i'm a i'm a big fan of
curate games so when i saw that this was coming out um
rather when i saw that it came out i was like oh i should
definitely play it but then i saw it saw it getting so
popular i was like no i even have even more reason to play
it i love curate games though they're so awesome time for
limited monetization that's okay did you ever play dream c
club oh my god meet it meet this any when i saw this i was
like this game is dream c club i saw oh my gosh it is so
funny that you mentioned that played Dream City Club and I'm
like someone else oh my gosh sorry I'm so I saw it when I
saw this game I was just like it's just Dream City Club but
like but you know oh my god ah thank you that made my night
oh my gosh i played so much dream city club so yes when i
saw this game i was very excited yeah my reaction to zoom
beanies yeah me too though me too but um i've played most of
made of the dead i think you'd have fun with that one too i
do want to play that one too i want to play Trouble Days,
like, went popular, like, went kind of mainstream.
Mainstream?
Not mainstream.
It was popular amongst VTubers some time ago.
I was thinking of playing maybe Prison Princess because
it's, like, kind of, like, a hidden objects game, but not
really.
It's, like, a point-and-click, a point-and-click, kind of, I
don't know.
Curate Marathon.
Yeah.
This game really reminded me of Left 4 Dead, though.
Really?
Doki Doki Literature Club I played that Just the VOD is It's
private It went Maid stream Speaking of maids I started
watching Akiba Maid Wars Like I've been watching that I
watched like the first three episodes of that I've been
watching The Konosuba anime Season 3 I've been watching Blue
Archive So That show is wild Yeah it feels like It feels
like Mades Meats Kakeguru Or something like that Are you
watching Dungeon Meshine?
No I want to start that one too though I want to start that
one too
Blue Archive Majang let's go That's the only reason.
It's the only reason I'm playing.
So I can maybe pull my...
Pull...
Who all is in?
Actually, let me check.
I saw that Shiroko was in it.
Blue Archive Magion.
So...
Um...
Mutsuki Aru...
Just those four?
I like Hoshino, I like Shiroko.
Do they talk in the game?
Do they, like, do you hear their VAs?
The Tokidoki literature club streams are my favorite.
Second to the Yomawari streams.
The Yomawari streams where I literally lose my brain, my
mind.
if i've gotten better if i try and go back and play it now
if i um if i'd be better i have shiruko and hoshino nice my
tubu i love the reaction when henia said she's serving her
country you get more voice lines for them if you level up
their bonding game you guys don't understand if ogura yui
voices something i either have to play it i have to watch If
I watch it, I have to do anything with it.
Always down for a redemption arc.
The Yo-Mawari final boss fight.
It still haunts me to this day.
If you didn't think, if you didn't know if a ghost could get
haunted or not, it haunts me to this day.
What's the first anime I watched?
It's hard to say because like I watched anime before I knew
like you know of like anime as a genre I get like if you
call if you can call it that you know a medium rather so I
watched like Pokemon and Sailor Moon and Dragon Ball a lot
of those and then I'd say the first I think the first that I
that like because like my sister's friend was just like oh
do you like watch anime and I was like I don't know what
that is and she showed me uh Inuyasha so um and then from
there I kind of watched Conan I got into Conan I got into
cowboy bebop you know I watched all those shows that were
fully fully cool all the shows that were on like cartoon
network and uh my sister would like show me shows too like
she showed me elfinly i don't know why she showed that to me
why do i keep lagging i think the game is too beefy
my neuro quirk re-zero season three airs in october
oh my gosh yes i also watched card captors i was cleaning i
moved some stuff around in my um in my maid cafe recently
and so um when i was doing that i was going through some old
books and i found this old card captors book that I like
have had since I was a kid.
I even still have the cloud cards that I've had since I was
a kid and like it's just like here's Sakura's friend
Madison.
So I watched that too.
I never I don't think I ever watched Tokyo Mew Mew.
I watched a little bit of Sergeant Frog.
adventure card captors do you know Sora no Aozora from
Dempogumi Inc oh none oh none I absolutely know Sora no
Aozora she's still she retired she no none she's in another
group it's called Arcana Project she left she left she left
Dempogumi but she is now in Arcana Project so you can still
listen to her her yeah yeah yeah oh i watched a little bit
of ham taro i think i only remember like watching so much of
hand talk or like like you know ham taro because of the you
know they always say like when they run around and stuff
what's my first impression of henya what do you mean she's
absolutely perfect she's my oshi there's nothing nothing
else that i can say about her she's perfect Everything that
she comes out of her mouth is gold.
It's genius.
She's her.
Yeah, she is.
She is her.
Yeah.
My Oshi.
I'm sorry to get tired, though.
Sorry to get tired.
I had a... I've been busy cleaning and doing some other
stuff.
So, um, I should probably go to sleep.
Oh, God, that way.
I actually, I can't stop yawning.
Thank you, guys, for hanging out with us.
I hope you had fun.
Hopefully it wasn't so chaotic, chaos craziness.
Um, oh, yeah, they...
That was so fun.
Thank you, guys.
My brain is mushed.
My brain is mush.
Mush, mush, mush.
We love chaos.
Tomorrow will be a little less chaos.
Sexy chaos.
Just came from Henya's dream.
More collabs.
Thanks for dropping by.
Thank you.
I see you also recommend look up this video if you want to
see her play Ace Combat 7.
She did PvP with one of the devs.
I will watch it.
She also really loves Gundam.
So, um, actually I forgot to tell her the last because the
last time I saw her I wanted to tell her to play Metal Gear.
I think she would really like Metal Gear so I want to tell
her to play it if she hasn't already.
It's not Mecha, but it's kind of...
I mean, Ace Combat's not Mecha either, but you know.
She's also like a Gundam ambassador though, so she's so
awesome.
She's so She's so perfect.
She's so cute.
I love, I love my Oshis.
The gift subs sure do clog up the dono notice.
They do.
I don't think I can turn them.
I don't know if I can turn them off, to be honest.
But, you know.
Yep.
Okie dokie.
I'm going to bed now.
Thank you guys.
Oh, I see your stream labs, Rico.
Consider investing in the laser guard dog rover and the more
taller sentry.
They make everything much easier by clearing a lot of the
trash for you.
We'll look into it.
Thank you.
Oh, my chat just disconnected.
I wonder if there's a way, though, I can turn off.
Because, you know, we don't need to see every... Oh!
Huh?
Uh-oh.
Wait, am I... I'm still streaming... Uh-oh.
Thank you, Seymour.
Uh.
So...
I don't know if I can end the stream.
Because I don't remember my password.
Uh.
It's asking me to verify my account.
I don't remember my password.
Um.
Hmm.
Uh, hmm.
Wait.
Uh.
Their password was changed 21 days ago.
Deleting system there.
Dude, I don't know.
Forgot password.
Text means recovery number.
Oh, there it is.
This is awkward, isn't it?
This sure is awkward.
Uh, oh yeah, I can, yeah, get the code.
Um, anyway, um, what do you, uh, um, what do you guys eat
for dinner?
If it's, if it's not dinner, what do you eat for, um, for
breakfast?
Taco Bell, burger, chicken, chicken, wing, beef, chicken,
chicken, chicken.
Pizza.
It's not even Friday.
Okay, update password.
You can update your password now if you forgot it.
Save password.
Change password.
Oh wait, it just locked me out or just kicked me out of
my...
Oh my god.
Wait.
This is so complicated.
Okay.
Save.
Thanks.
Okay, what was I doing?
Oh, I was signing into YouTube to end my stream.
I'm going to end my stream now.
Thank you guys for hanging out today.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for hanging out.
I hope you enjoyed.
the collab and um get some rest.
Otsuminto!
Bye bye!
Otsuboistin!
Otsuminto!
Bye bye bye!
Bye bye bye bye!
Good night!